After the SDV gets as close as it can, dispose of it, from
there on you'll have to swim.
Oh my god.
High-tech Special Forces Unit Foxhound.
Your former unit, and one that I was a commander of.
So they're still around.
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist
activity.
Psycho Mattis, with his powerful psychic abilities.
Dead.
Sniper Wolf, a beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
Decoy Octopus.
Dead.
Master of Disguise.
Vulcan Raven.
And Shaman.
And Revolver Ocelot, Specialist in Interrogation, and a
formidable gunfighter.
And finally, in charge of them, Foxhound Squad Leader.
Liquid Snake.
Liquid snake.
The man with the same code name as you.
The nuclear weapons disposal study covers the whole island.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
Anyone going with me?
Don't look at my panty.
This is a one-man infiltration mission.
Weapons equipment OSP?
Yes.
This is a top-secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
That's just like my real head.
Oh my god.
Why do you swim like that?
I'm as elegant as a dolphin.
What are you talking about?
Hello everybody!
Welcome back to Metal Gear Solid Integral.
Press the start button.
Welcome back, welcome back, welcome back.
Did you notice something a little special about...
about the game.
Isn't it cold AF in Alaska in your main outfit?
Don't worry, I'm a ghost.
It doesn't even matter.
Snake is cute.
He's always cute.
What are you talking about?
Seems pretty normal to me.
Yes.
I am playing the mod swapped version.
Where I will be.
Solid Snake!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
No more.
There we go.
Hello, boss.
Good to have you with us.
So, actually, Jeremy hooked me up with like a save of where
I was at exactly, basically.
So, we're just picking up where we left off, but instead of
Snake, it's me.
so thank you thank you guys for helping me out with getting
this all set up especially in time for the finale ghosts
don't belong in Alaska so yeah I'm so excited I'm nervous
let's see let's see how it looks oh my gosh oh my gosh Nah,
we don't need to read the mission log, the Lition Mog.
Mom!
I made that!
Wait, can I Beyblade?
Woo!
Yeah!
Let her rip!
Are you also Liquid Snake?
since they're wait oh it disappeared what the heck that
thank you for the sabotage yeah here I go oh my gosh look at
me oh my gosh in the future I should commission a like me
and a sneaking suit model right oh my gosh look at me look
at me
okay got my stuff I got full rations I'll I got my other
stuff okay we're all good I think look at me it's so cute I
did not expect a bench mod is pretty awesome right oh my
gosh mom I'm in the game Oh my gosh, it's so awesome.
Oh, man.
Oh, I already have rash.
Wait, how's my health anyway?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, full.
We're set to go, baby.
We're set to go.
The legendary solid mint.
Yes!
So today we will be completing Metal Gear Solid.
We got a little bit to go, so it'll be a little bit but
hopefully hopefully we can believe in my gamer abilities my
abilities as a soldier as a gamer congrats on debuting on
your first of many metal gear universe on live stream love
can bloom on the battlefield soul and mint is a ghost why
doesn't she go through the walls to stop wrecks fake ghost
hey i'm doing this fair and square okay fair and square um
but uh yeah So, uh, I don't really know what else to say.
I'm nervous about fighting Vulcan Raven because he's so
difficult, but, um, I'll do my, my Rubesti.
How do I look in the box?
It probably looks the same, right?
Oh, you can see my little feet.
Yeah, it looks the same, right?
Oh man What would be funny All of the Metal Gear series That
is 3D Changes Snake To Mint After this game Peace Walker To
MGS3 I don't know A 4 and 5 modded Once I get a 3D model
Maybe we can put it I feel like by the time I get around to
playing 5 By the time I get around of playing five i will
have to have a 3d model by then right no sneaking suit
during the liquid fist fight right how is that gonna how is
that gonna look wait jeremy are they gonna take off my
clothes?
Jeremy!
Wait!
Am I gonna be...
Am I gonna be finally getting my undies?
What's going on?
No?
Oh man, you are not gonna be naked.
Man, you had an opportunity!
Maybe you should fix it.
for when everybody else uses this mod.
Can't wait for Metal Gear 1 and 2 mod.
I'll be there no matter what.
We won't be streaming on my birthday.
Booy!
Happy early birthday!
I'll sing real fast so we can suddenly get into the... I'm
quite busy today, actually.
I was like, oh my gosh, should I be even streaming such a
long thing?
Because I have so much to do before tomorrow, but it's okay.
Instead, I edited a video that I didn't need to necessarily
put out, and then also I worked on this.
So, you know, I think I used my time wisely instead of
packing and practicing.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Wii.
Happy birthday to you
Alright guys I don't remember the strat for beating Vulcan
Raven So I think it's like Just put C4 down and don't forget
where you put it
Oh my gosh We're gonna see the cutscene with me This is
gonna be crazy Why is my mouth like Like a cat shape Oh my
gosh I can't see anything Oh my god, it's so bright.
My eyes!
Welcome, Cossack.
This is the end of the road for you.
Right, my friends?
Listen, they agree.
Lime, happy birthday.
Happy birthday, dear you.
They're simply returning to the natural world.
Happy birthday, dear Lime.
Happy birthday, dear.
Sometimes they even attack wounded foxes.
You were the one in the M1 tank.
Vigrasek deserves all the thanks for getting this thing off
the ground.
Vigrasek!
Thank you.
Thank you so much!
I feel like crying.
I'm so happy.
The Ravens and I were testing to see what kind of man you
were.
It's so funny because I look so anime in this.
Ravens say you are a true warrior.
That's an eagle.
Oh, oh, oh.
I look so...
Everybody doesn't have an...
Oh my god!
I can't move.
The raven has put the mark of death upon you.
The ravens are me.
But from the east flows within your wings.
I'm a Japanese princess!
Ah, your ancestors too were raised on the barren plains of
Apollo.
Oh my gosh, my eyes are so close to each other.
I can't move.
We share many ancestors, you and I.
I don't have any crows in my family tree.
You just, but indeed ravens and snakes are not the best of
friends.
you will make a worthy adversary yes you live in Alaska too
you know of the world Eskimo Indian Olympics yeah I know it
must be a real threat in the muck duck eating contest yes
you are right but there is another event that I excel at it
is called the earpool it is an event where two opponents
pull each other's ears while enduring the harsh cold never
would have thought of that as well as physical strength.
The ear pull.
You want to pull each other's ears?
I look so smug!
Rejoice, Snake.
Ours will be a glorious battle.
This isn't glorious.
It's just plain killing.
Violence isn't a sport.
Yeah, violence isn't a sport.
We'll see if there's iron in your words.
Uh oh.
Oh oh.
Ah!
Oh my gosh.
I'm not ready.
I'm not ready for this battle.
Oh my gosh.
Don't see me!
Okay, let's see.
Does stun grenades work on him?
I have quite a bit, actually.
Run, me, don't run!
On
the claymores, I won't remember where I do it.
I don't remember.
Stuns don't work, okay, okay.
Maybe I could Nikita missile him.
And remember that that's technically a way you can do it.
Um...
Let's see.
Oh my gosh.
He's coming this way!
Wait, he knows where I am.
How does he know where I am?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Run me!
Don't run!
Okay, uh, how do I shoot this thing again?
Um...
Oh no!
It's all in.
It's not... Okay, so the Master Collection would like make
it to be like A, B, X, Y.
Okay, so X is A.
Square is X.
Oh gosh.
B is O.
Y is triangle.
This will confuse me, surely.
This surely won't confuse me.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Ah!
Don't come this way.
Maybe if I leave.
Okay, maybe if I bait him.
for the C4.
Okay.
Wait, okay.
Square button and then B button.
Okay.
Bait, bait.
Bait him, bait him, bait him.
Bait him, bait him.
Wait, what the hell am I wearing?
Oh, that's my hair.
Go up.
No!
Don't go!
Hey, man.
Hey, you're going the wrong way!
Okay, let's try and the key the missile again.
struggling on this quite a bit.
Wait.
Where is he, though?
Oh my god.
There he is.
Ah!
You son of a gun.
Wait, wait, wait.
He's coming back.
He can...
Come on.
Go up, go up, go up.
Okay.
I know I saw.
Go up, go up, go up, go up, go up towards me, go up towards
me!
Yeah, nice, nice, nice, nice.
This is actually good.
Keep going, keep going.
Yeah!
Maybe I should have put one where I just stood.
Okay, hold on.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna put one right here.
Slow and steady, everybody.
Slow and steady.
Wait, where did I put it?
Right here.
In the middle, in the middle, in the middle, in the middle.
In the middle.
Wait, no, he's coming up through the middle.
Turn.
Turn, like, turn to the right.
Yes, yes, yes.
Wait, I'm gonna put one here?
Oh, wait.
It's gonna explode the first one, though, right?
Oh, shoot.
He's going in the same pattern.
Wonderfield...
I'm right here, dummy!
Snake looks cute.
My hair is so green here.
Wait, sorry.
Okay.
Put down.
Oh, button.
Oh, God.
Oh no, he's doing his little running bit now.
Oh!
Oh my god.
He's scaring me.
I'm gonna put one down here again.
He seems to like to come over here.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Come over here!
Why?
He's like huffing and puffing.
I think he's struggling.
What the?
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god,
oh my god.
Oh, nice.
You jerk!
Maybe I could have gotten him, but...
Does knocking lower him?
I don't think so.
Dang!
Oh my god, oh my god.
I know this is like the slowest ever, but...
Stop running!
Stop running.
Why are you running?
Oh my god.
Come on up!
a cat and like this is exactly what it's like to call for a
cat they just don't listen to you remember the basics of cqc
against this guy oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
nice oh he's still going oh he's still running oh my god
he's still running
Stop running!
You're scaring me!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Which way is...
You're scaring me!
Oh my god, oh my god.
Stop running, Raven!
Please, Vulcan Raven, please!
He's really getting his cardio in, man.
He's like going at it.
Come on, come on.
This is the strat.
Oh, it did barely, but that's okay.
I'm scared of him.
I think I put it...
Oh, dang it!
Wait, where did I put it, actually?
In... Okay, right there, right there.
Sorry, I have to be, like, really meticulous or slow about
this.
You know, meticulous, because I...
I will forget otherwise.
Okay.
It's mint mode.
It's mint mode!
Oh, hold on.
Hold on.
hold your horses come on he's going up oh my god I
accidentally put another one down it's right here it's a
right there I might have to go find some more oh my gosh oh
my gosh don't find me don't don't see me don't see me don't
see me don't see me don't see me don't see me don't see me
don't see me okay I'm gonna have to blow this one up first
okay all right Come up here.
Use the clay more.
Oh, I'm afraid of running over it though, for real.
Whew, that was close.
Don't come down.
Don't, I said no, don't come down.
All right, now go up.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Keep going up.
Nice.
This is how we do it, guys.
We're almost there, we're almost there.
We're gaming.
Playmore's in the inner range.
He's looking at him running around.
Like crazy.
Paper bags!
Thank you for the vibe gifted!
I know I should set up some more, but it's also like getting
it.
It's fine, you guys.
It's fine.
He's running around.
He's like so tired.
Keep going up.
Keep going.
up nice this is not speedrun strats but that's okay oh my
god oh my god wait no he's
he is put a claymore in his path i'm so scared i'm so scared
of getting blown out wait oh my rashes are frozen oh shoot
okay hold on i'll put one here oh my gosh oh my gosh scary
scary scary scary scary okay he's coming up I think he's
gonna come up I have to be careful though not to not to get
blown up by the claymores if he comes around it's fine it's
good oh what was that he can see the claymores too though
right okay I'm gonna run.
Ah!
Oh my god.
This is...
Oh, this is bad.
Oh, my rations are free, though.
Yeah!
Oh, oh, Vince!
Go back to where?
Wait.
Okay.
Did that ever blow up?
Oh my god.
Wait a second.
Uh, wait.
It's, uh...
Okay, square button.
Here he comes.
Maybe.
He's close.
You exploded your C4.
Not me, right?
Oh my god.
Don't come up here.
Unless you do.
He's exploding my hiding spots.
Here he comes.
Just as the boss said.
It is my existence.
Which is no longer needed in this world.
Nice.
First try.
Yippee.
My body will not remain in this place.
My spirit and my flesh will become one with the Ravens.
In that way, I will return to Mother Earth.
I was so nervous I was shaking.
I think it's also from...
I'm hungry.
Snake!
I will be watching you.
Nibio.
Understand?
Devin, thanks for the 10 gift, dude!
Snake, take this security card.
It will open that door.
Why are you helping me?
Why?
You are a snake which was not created by nature.
I look so happy.
You and the boss.
You are from another world.
A world that I do not wish to know.
Go and do battle with him.
I will be watching from above.
First, I'll give you a hint.
A hint.
you saw die before your eyes the diaper chief stinky that
guy yeah the diaper chief I like the cat mouth but I just
said it was the diaper chief me do something decoy octopus
easiest body Best battle ever.
He was a master of disguise.
He copied his subjects down to the blood.
That's why he was drained of blood!
So he drained the chief's blood and took it into himself.
Oh my god, his face!
Oh my god, oh my god.
But he wasn't able to deceive the angel of death.
What?
The angel of death.
What'd you do with his body?
Killed him with cringe.
He's like animated anime why go to so much trouble why
impersonate the chief why impersonate the chief?
That is the end of my hint you must solve the rest of the
riddle yourself Peculiar how this part is all metal There's
no such thing as boundless slaughter.
There's always an end to it You are different trying to say
the path you walk on has no end each step you take is paved
with the corpses of your enemies their souls will haunt you
forever you shall have no peace so awesome look at me go my
spirit will be watching you
they gobble that guy up they ate him so fast
master miller snake it's me master it's about Naomi go to
jean sama miller colonel is Naomi there no she's away she's
taking a short nap oh it must be nice i'm fighting for my
life and she's napping okay maybe we'll better let the
colonel hear this too i'll be watching you subs to my
channel well basically dr naomi hunter is not dr naomi
hunter at all what what i thought her story of her
background sounded kind of fishy so i checked it out and
there is an actual dr naomi hunter or i should say there was
one oh but she's not the woman we know the real naomi hunter
disappeared somewhere in the Middle East our Naomi must have
somehow obtained her identification papers uh oh so then who
is she really she must be some kind of spy a spy yes maybe
she's been sent to sabotage this operation are you saying
she's with the terrorists I don't want to believe it either
but she is working for Foxhound so you think she had a part
in the uprising or she could be working with some different
group altogether different group it couldn't be place her
under a risk whoa what she's betrayed us she needs to be
arrested yeah arrest her arrest her yeah she's one of their
spies and we're in big trouble tracks are welcome thank you
nothing have you let her in on some kind of vital secret or
something colonel colonel does this have anything to do with
of the DARPA chief and the arms tech president.
The door.
Colonel!
Anyway, we cannot allow her to participate any further in
this mission.
Wait, wait a minute.
Without her, we can't complete this mission.
Why not?
You are hiding something.
Uh-oh.
Give me some time.
I'll try to get it out of her.
Ooh.
Hurry then.
We've got to figure out who she is and what she's doing
here.
I understand.
Colonel!
Give me some time.
We're out of time!
Yeah!
Oh, I love that.
I don't have any time left for you.
So awesome.
Oh, my health is like...
There's still ration and stuff over here, though, right?
We'll just take this.
Let's go around and grab some stuff.
All good.
Oh, what's that?
My cute on my souls.
Nice.
Take the minigun.
Oh, there we go.
wow no wonder he's like huffing and puffing around oh so
good i like that there's a way to like um look at each
corpse you know virulent thanks for the vibe give to it so
guys um it was a slow process but we gamed and now we
continue onward what how many um let's see okay 17 chaff
grenades and we'll get more later we'll need one for that
one room coming up oh i forgot to say this ahu said the crow
is that does that sound crows make um please no spoilers not
for me but for anyone who is watching that hasn't played the
series before.
If you see a spoiler, please use to get it off the screen.
Thank you.
There you go.
Pin.
All right.
Oh, wait.
Thank you, Joshua!
Have you ever heard of Guyver?
Yes, the one that David Hater is.
Yeah, that plays.
I have.
I haven't watched it yet, though.
This is so funny.
Okay, so like I said, they gave me this save because...
Because, obviously, this is not from the Master Collection.
And Jerry goes next to the 20 Gifted!
But there's no Nostasia.
There's no Merrill.
there's no maryland here i don't know anything about dr
naomi so there's not much i can say okay but snake i think
you'd better leave that to colonel campbell don't you think
you'd better just get to the control room fine okay master
miller gochujin sama snake i'm sure that woman calling
herself naomi is some type of spy and now i'm starting to
think that Campbell might be hiding something too don't
trust him you're making me nervous check the back of the box
Naomi wasn't acting strangely or anything no I just can't
believe that Naomi's an enemy spy I refused to accept that I
don't want to believe it either but don't say it's snake my
favorite spoiler about this game is the part where the metal
gears become solid It's so impactful.
Yeah, it's a really good part, you know?
Say, but you...
Oh, she doesn't even say anything to me.
First time watching MGS gameplay.
I didn't know the character that David Hater voices in this
particular game is so cute.
So cute.
I know I won't be bored with things about.
Doesn't it kind of surreal, though?
Snake, if it's about Naomi, I'm looking into the matter
right now.
now we don't have time colonel where is she where is she
still sleeping what wake her up leave it first the darpa
chief turns out to be an imposter and now naomi what the
hell is going on here just finishing i suppose you're going
to tell me you don't know anything right i'm sorry snake ah
madman is threatening the world with a nuclear weapon i'm so
disappointed in you i'm so disappointed in you uh i think i
got everything that i can get from this area, so let's just
move onwards.
Oh.
Level 7 now, baby.
Let's go!
Okay.
That's a trap.
Oh, look!
They even give me some more!
Because they know that this room is just ridiculous.
Look at this!
What is going on in here?
Even if I shoot those down, there's more, aren't there?
On the other side?
I wonder if I can shoot them down, though.
Wouldn't it be kind of fun?
Oh, can I even...
Oh, I can't even reach.
I'm too...
I can't look out.
Stinger missile?
Will that work?
No use.
Don't look at my sker!
What are you doing?
Don't look at my skirt, what are you doing?
Oh, because I'm laid down.
Let's try it again.
I wish I could target all of them, though.
But I should save these, shouldn't I?
Won't the cameras be...
Won't they be re-put up later on?
and there's like a ton of them the solid mint implied liquid
doki i'm trying to like decide which would be better to use
the chaff probably just the chaff we'll save the stinger for
for future fight we'll need the chaff for future fight too
you get lots of stingers you do
no i tried sniping them already hmm revolver doki makes more
sense yeah i think Okay, so I think if we were to replace
the models with people, I think Matara could be liquid
snake.
I think Doki would have to be revolver us a lot.
I was thinking maybe like Henya could be psychomantic.
Because it's, I don't know, I feel like a psychic is in like
the same leagues as a genius, you know?
Revolver Doki.
Tenya could be Otacon.
That would...
Oh!
I guess that works even better, right?
Also, I don't know in the save which ending we're going to
get.
I originally played to get the Merrill ending.
Um, I have no idea if...
So it will be gotcha.
Don't tell me!
Jeremy, if you're still here, don't tell me.
Don't tell me.
Don't tell me, don't tell me.
I want it to be a surprise.
So, um, we will see what happens.
Okay.
I'm gonna, uh, oh my god.
Okay, you know what?
There's no way I'm using this.
Look at this.
Look at all of them on the, this is, no.
No.
Okay, yeah.
Using the Stinger is totally useless.
There's too many.
Uh, how do I throw?
Here we go.
Stinger!
Missile!
Why did they put...
It's almost time.
I'm so excited here.
I'm turning the volume up.
Are you guys ready?
It starts with a Z.
Are you running this mod on actual hardware Minto?
like this you'd be the person to get a japanese ps1 to play
this i'm not gonna lie i 100 thought about it but i did not
have time to set it up but i did i did really want to all
right here we go
Whoa!
Rex!
Zoom!
Take that for sure.
Oh, there's a camera there.
Zoom!
Wait, wait, wait!
Keep moving!
Ah!
Not this way!
Move the other way!
Oh, I don't think it goes anymore.
Okay, that's fine.
We'll have to go down there anyway later on.
Otagon!
What's wrong?
Did you find a good place to hide?
Yeah, thanks to the stealth gear.
It looks like they've finished getting Metal Gear ready.
Oh, no.
How do you know that?
I overheard them talking.
Oh, no!
Where are you now?
in front of metal gear but it's strange what is there's
nobody here no guards nobody patrolling it's too quiet maybe
because they're all ready they said they even input the pall
no what should i do all we can do is use the override system
that president baker told you about but i've only got one of
the three keys and besides that like ocelot said there's
some trick to using the keys leave it to me you got some
kind of plan well i'm in the computer room right now i'm
trying to access baker's private files baker's files don't
you need a password of course but there are ways he's
hawking are you a hacker yep that describes me pretty well
does it look like you can get in i don't know you i'm
counting on you
and oh don't look up my skirt please
Oh, I don't remember where the guards are around here.
They're upstairs, right?
Wow!
Dude.
Oh, that keeps calling me.
Not a con!
How's it going?
Uh, not bad.
I just got past his third security level.
That was fast.
He was a pretty careful guy.
Do you think you'll break in soon?
Why don't you guys just stay on the phone?
I couldn't bust into.
Keep trying.
Jump.
All right, here we go.
Don't look.
Oh.
Stop!
Oh,
there's some stuff.
I'll go grab all that.
Famous.
Greetings, Germany.
Second time watching VTuber.
my viewer passed away from animal money goes towards save
the frames krill the DARPA chief or bustin can I get a hi
passed away from animal I'm so sorry for your laws.
Oh, nope.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, we haven't seen me.
Kick!
Wow!
Nice!
That's a completely responsible parent.
I am so proud of my boy.
Yeah!
Doesn't he call me here?
Snake, I did it!
He did it!
You got bad security?
Bingo.
Great.
So what do you got?
What do you got?
metal gear file so what about the pal override system that
Baker talked about I haven't found it yet that's what I need
to know but snake I found something else what what the
secret behind the new nuclear weapon who just as I thought
the nuclear warhead is designed to be fired from the railgun
like a projectile okay it doesn't use fuel so it isn't
considered a missile this is craziness around all sorts of
international treaties pretty sneaky yes but And that's not
even the scariest thing about this weapon.
Uh-oh.
I can't wait to hear this.
It's a stealth weapon.
You mean it won't show up on radar?
That's crazy!
The truth is they've been working on a stealth missile since
the late 70s.
Uh-oh.
Why weren't they able to develop one until now?
Because of the missile rocket propulsion system.
It would be picked up by enemy satellites.
Oh yeah, that makes sense.
But unlike a missile, the railgun doesn't burn any
propellant, so it can't be detected by any current ballistic
missile detection system.
systems.
Uninvisible nuclear warhead.
That's so scary.
And on top of that, it's got a surface piercing warhead
designed to penetrate hardened underground bases.
They just were like, let's take everything back.
This thing could mean the end of the world.
It's the ultimate weapon.
And from a political point of view, it avoids the problem of
nuclear reduction and nuclear inspections.
Colonel, is this true?
Are you listening?
Uh, Colonel?
If word of this got out, it could delay the signing of the
Star 3 treaty and cause a huge international incident.
Yeah, it would be nasty.
The United States would be denounced by the UN.
It could even bring the president down.
Did you know this, Colonel?
I'm sorry.
Oh, Colonel.
You changed, Colonel.
You've changed, Colonel.
I won't make any excuses.
Snake, listen to me.
This new nuclear weapon, it's never actually been tested,
only simulated.
apart the minute like they tried to shoot the missile they
don't even know if it works what were the results of the
exercise it looks like it went better than it was put
together by the by Boeing staff the data as important as
that would be carefully recorded it was don't sit by the
exit see hello from Scotland I hope you prevent World War
three and took it from me the terrorists have replaced the
dummy warhead with a real warhead once they input the
detonation codes they should be ready to launch so you think
they can do it well the dummy warhead was designed to be
identical to the better person did you find out how to
override it yet not yet it must be in a separate file right
now i'm looking through all of baker's personal files
warheads from tibu oh my god no i'm I'm warheads from TiVu!
Okay, so he's like over...
There he is.
How can I get his butt?
Gosh, I wish there was first person...
First person choosing.
I don't remember what his...
What his route is like.
Let's see.
I think he only goes... Oh!
Hi!
You don't see me?
This guy gives this guy some glasses.
I could technically maybe go now.
How long does he stay over there?
He'll probably...
How long is he over there for?
Nikita for a challenge?
I'm just gonna launch a Nikita missile at this poor dude?
He's over there for a while.
Does he come over here?
I don't think so.
Do it now.
The Nikita missile?
Will it even let me?
No use!
It won't let me.
How bored.
Wait, what about a stinger though?
No way!
Wait.
Oh, oh.
Oh, you're not coming this way, are you?
Ah!
Oh.
Okay, he stops right there.
Hey, buddy.
I just saved your life.
I just saved your life, man.
Can they still hear my footsteps if I'm in the box?
Can you snipe them?
Oh, maybe.
Actually, I don't think so, because I'll lay down, and it'll
be, like, all annoying.
Did he hear me?
Yeah?
I'm kind of busy.
I haven't found out about the override system yet.
But I found Baker's ulterior motive.
He's just looking to get rich, isn't he?
Arms Tech is in much worse financial trouble than I thought.
I know they lost their bid to make the next generation
fighter jet.
That plus the reduction in SDI's spending.
How's the audio, by the way?
It's kind of hard for me to gauge.
So I'm really sorry if it's kind of off.
If you're too loud or whatever.
And it looks like we were paying a lot of bribe money to the
DARPA chief.
Bride money, huh?
And Baker was a big proponent of the nuclear deterrent
theory.
I see.
Slightly quiet.
But what about the override?
Just give me a little bit longer.
I feel like the music is kind of loud, which is why...
Oh, oh, he's coming back.
We'll save right here.
Huh?
Oh.
Just a box.
wait where are you going oh no no you're not get out of the
way oh my god are you serious right oh are you serious right
now uh which was cqc oh wait
i'm hidden i'm hiding okay i've ended the pal codes and
disengaged the safety device oh they're Whoa.
Whoa.
There's still no response from Russia.
Whoa, they're so blurry.
It looks like we'll have to show them that we mean business.
Should I set it for Cherniton, Russia?
No.
There's been a change.
The new target is Lopnor, China.
Why, boss?
Look, you can see my hand.
I'm sure neither you nor Mr. Kulukovic would really like to
see a nuclear bomb dropped on your motherland, right?
Oh, liquid.
But why?
There's nothing there.
Wrong.
nuclear test site.
If we nuke a major population center, the game's over.
Is that solid, Nico?
It is!
But a nuclear explosion at a test site can still be
concealed from the public.
Meanwhile, Washington will be worried about the retaliatory
strike from China.
That'll probably mean top-secret talks between both
countries leaders.
Not top-secret.
Of course.
And in the process, the president will be forced to divulge
the existence of a new and highly destabilizing nuclear do
you think that will do to the US's reputation you don't want
to subscribe to me that means the China and India I see yes
when the other countries hear about this new weapon they'll
all want to contact us if you are Washington won't be very
happy when we start selling their own system to the highest
bidders you don't have to subscribe if you don't want to
president will break he will give into our demands big
bosses dna and one billion one billion dollars that money
will be used to cure our genome soldiers as well i'm also
including the fox die vaccine in our demands fox die fox die
he killed octopus in the arms tech president so it's true
that it affects older people first mantis might not have
been affected because he wore a mask mask up everybody wolf
wasn't infected Because she's too hot to die.
She always took.
Oh, never mind.
Something to do with the adrenaline level in the blood.
I could not chat.
I can't doubt.
Sorry to give you that.
We're still experimental.
And they haven't worked out all the bugs yet.
I was just kidding, but they did.
In any case, have you heard from your friend, Colonel Sergei
Golukovic, at the Spetsnaz?
Oh, Golukovic.
He still has doubts about the ability of Metal Gear.
He said we can talk after Metal Gear's testing.
launch is successful yeah yeah yeah i don't blame him he's a
very prudent man i don't blame him there's nothing to worry
about the colonel wants metal gear and a new nuclear weapon
so bad he can taste it if russia wants to regain its
position as a military superpower you need to reinforce
their nuclear arsenal you need a nuclear weapon that can't
be intercepted metal gear will allow them to gain first
strike capability over the rest of the world their regular
army is and they think they can restore their country's
military power with nuclear weapons.
Kalukovic, he's no warrior.
He's a politician.
He's the one who gave us the hind and most of our other
heavy firepower.
He's got over a thousand soldiers under his command.
If we join forces, we could put up quite a resistance here.
Yeah, Rex is pretty cute.
Since Mantis died, the Genome Soldier's brainwasher has
started to wear off.
I'm worried about the man's morale.
An alliance with the Russians would boost that as well.
saying we're not going anywhere we're going to dig in here
okay you can still escape we've got the most powerful weapon
ever made and we're about to ally with galukovic's forces
are you going to fight the whole world spaghetti hair and
what's wrong with that we can launch a nuclear warhead at
any target on this planet a nuclear warhead invisible to
radar and on top of that this base is full of spare nuclear
warheads once we get the we got everything we need here we
can The nuclear warheads.
What about your promise to Colonel Galukovic?
I have a flight to Japan!
I have no interest in the revival of Mother Russia!
You're not thinking of reviving Big Boss's dream.
From today, call this place...
Outer Heaven.
Oh!
Big Boss's dream.
Mito looks at the camera.
You're not worried about the pal being overridden.
Big Boss's dream.
If the code is in it again, it'll be deactivated.
There's no need to worry.
Wait, that's not me?
Does Snake know how the override system works?
That's not me.
Don't you know?
He didn't have any keys on him.
Then no one can stop Metal Gear now.
By the way, what should we do with that woman?
Want me to kill her?
Oh wait.
Let her live.
She's Campbell's niece and Snake cares about her.
Wait, so she's alive?
We'll keep her as our ace in the hole.
Or maybe we don't.
Beryl.
She's alive.
The fourth wall is struggling.
Snake, I found Baker's top secret files.
Let's go.
Great job.
How's it going there?
They've finished inputting the PAL codes.
Oh my god.
So how do we deactivate them?
Okay.
You see the override system that the president was talking
about.
It can also be used to input the detonation codes.
Okay.
You see, if you insert the keys when the warhead is active,
you deactivate it.
and if you insert them when it's inactive it becomes
activated okay you can only use the keys once okay once huh
yeah you better get started we don't have much time but it
takes three keys right i've only got one of them hold on a
minute you see that's the trick you already have all three
keys what are you talking about the card key is made of a
shape memory alloy shape memory alloy yes There's a trick!
Chains of shape at different temperatures.
The key is made out of it.
This card key.
What if I just warm it up between my cheeks?
You think it'll be hot enough?
At different temperatures.
So this key is actually three keys and one.
Clever.
Can you see the input terminals in the center of the control
room?
I can.
I see them.
Those three laptop terminals are for the emergency input.
Okay.
There should be a symbol on each screen.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
corresponds to a different key like it feels like Pokemon
input the keys in order from left to right okay the left
ones for the room temperature key see the symbol yeah next
to that goes the low temperature the one on the right is the
high temperature yeah okay I got it first I changed the
shape of the card and then I input them in order right
that's right all you do is insert the card
disk reads the information contained on it once you've
finished with all three terminals the code input process is
complete but here's the thing what are they doing you can
only use the key three times okay it's an emergency system
it's only meant to be used once wait so then how have they
used the whole world is riding all that key snake hey shut
up my key god why would you do this to me The key fell on
the drain.
It's dead.
Oh, my God.
Snake.
Who made that sound effect?
Bulletproof glass.
There's no way in.
I'll enjoy watching you die.
Don't lock me out, Liquid.
Let me into your heart.
Snake, you've got to get that key.
Mint, you've got to get that key.
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Whoa, whoa, wait.
I'm just gonna run.
Wait.
Ah!
I'm not gonna just run.
Um.
Was this from before?
Seriously?
Bye.
Yeah, dummies.
I got a key to get it.
Please.
Leave me alone.
Is that a mod?
Absolutely.
Look what their minto eyes.
Nothing.
Wait, here's...
Zoom!
Pre-order bonus.
This is from the base game.
Yeah.
I've always been there, you guys.
I like how...
Like, when you look at me from the...
From, like, the bottom up, I just look really bald
underneath.
Like, my head has been shaved, you know?
Wait, wasn't there a way... Oh, right here.
Oh, here.
There we go.
Alright, let's go into some acid water.
I don't remember where it's at.
Nice.
There's also bombs under here, aren't there?
Wait!
Oh, see, yeah, yeah.
Oh!
Nice, nice.
Uh, how do I get... avoid that?
Okay, nice.
Is it over here by...
I can't remember where it's at.
Taking a dip in the forbidden drawing.
This is Beat Tuber Bathwater.
That's the card?
Are you sure?
Isn't that the card key?
Solid Snake's greatest ally, Matterment.
Are you guys sure?
I think the dot is the card, but it's...
But it's the mine detector.
The card should show up with the mine detector.
I'm scared.
Call Otakon, you're so right.
You're so right.
The terrorists are finished inputting the detonation.
Otakon, I lost the key!
I'm a boy, mate.
I interrupted because I'm dodgy.
You need that key to do it.
Find that key, Snake.
There's no other way.
I had to go on!
Call Master.
Find that key.
It fell somewhere in that drainage ditch.
Use your mind detector.
Mind detector.
Yes, the mind detector works just like a metal detector.
The position of the card key should show up on your radar
screen.
We found it!
Thanks, Colonel.
Master Miller.
You lost the key?
Hurry up and find it.
They've already entered the detonation code.
The only way to stop that launch is to lock the system by
re-inputting the detonation codes.
If you use the mind detector, you should be able to find the
key.
Even if it fell into the drainage ditch.
Whatever you do, find that key.
He's disappointed in me.
I'm sorry, Master.
Loving this Phantom Snake mod.
Stay based.
Good girl.
Thank you.
Okay.
Oh, we got a bomb!
That's not the car key!
Snake, did you find the key?
No, I found the bomb!
It's not here.
Don't be ridiculous.
You saw it fall into the drainage ditch, didn't you?
Thank you so much.
The drainage ditch.
Isn't there something odd about it?
No, there are a lot of big rats though.
That's it, Snake.
A rat must have eaten it.
Now it was being ridiculous.
No, I'm right.
There's no other possibility.
sorts of things.
There's nothing unusual about that.
What?
The rat ate the key?
I don't feel like I ever heard this before.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oi!
Throw it!
Wait, how do I get it out of my... Oh, there we go.
Oi!
Oh, that was close.
Mine detector!
Hey, rat.
Did you eat the key?
Oh, no way.
He's literally up there.
Unless he ate a bomb.
Oh my god, stupid rat.
Did you eat a bomb, stupid rat?
Where'd he go?
Wait.
Little rat.
Where'd you go with the key?
You were here!
Zoom.
What?
Is it?
Oh, I found him.
Yo, yo, no, you don't crawl in there.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, he's going around.
I'm watching him.
I'm watching him crawl through the pipes.
Oh, just right.
He's down that way.
Little rat.
Where is he?
Is he down here?
I think he's down here.
Maybe.
Wait.
This is such an awesome angle.
I've never seen this angle before.
I don't think.
Oh my gosh, it's so awesome!
Oh shoot, the red is...
Oh, there he is.
Okay.
I think I keep spooking him.
I don't remember this part at all, I'll be honest.
Is this from Integral?
Is this like a special Integral thing?
Or...
I don't remember.
I don't...
Can we replace the rats with tiny minto's?
Little rat!
Oh, it's random, no way.
That's crazy.
Oh, little rat!
You going back this way?
I'll meet you there.
I'm gonna put a bomb.
I'm gonna... I'm gonna blow up this rat.
Wait, he left!
Oh, he left.
Would it be funny if the rat turned out to be leading you
into a colony of Zanzibar hamsters?
Oh, where did he go?
This stupid guy.
Okay, we need to see where he kind of hangs out and then
like...
Oh, get up.
Get up there.
Oh, you stupid.
Where does he even come from here?
I can't even tell.
It has to do with how many alerts you get.
Low equals right.
Does that mean I'm doing well?
No way.
The other thing's at it's random, though.
That's so awesome.
I did well enough to get the red.
Where did he go, though?
Oh.
Where the hell is he?
Why didn't he blow up?
Wait, oh no, that's my bomb.
I'm an idiot.
Wait, he might blow up now.
What?
I got it!
It's okay, the death happened off screen.
I'm an idiot, though.
I can't believe I was like, hey, that's my...
Where's the red?
I can't see him, you guys.
It's a ghost red.
Pinto love, thank you.
Thank you, Jekyll Blaze.
Thank you.
I kind of want to go get that ration.
I know it's craziness, but...
Nah, it's okay.
I'll go without.
How does it taste?
Yeah, they were giving us a little...
A little sneak peek of...
Of three.
Guide says under 10 alerts is the right.
There's no way I did that well.
There's no way.
Minto gaming?
Some heating or cooling pipes you can shoot?
No.
Binary ghost, that's actually only for...
That's actually only for...
What's it called?
Twin snakes.
Unfortunately, for this, we have to backtrack.
I want to get this guy's butt.
Maybe I can get him from when he's right here.
Because if he sees my box, he kicks me over.
Jerk.
Use the stinger.
Yeah, I think I will.
I think I will stinger his face.
Will it kill him, though?
Maybe this from this close, it should.
right come on over he's gonna die good oh didn't you say
this was a different save yeah you're so right no wonder i
was like there's no way i had less than than 10.
that's not my fault that is the That's not my fault.
That's not my fault!
The Stinger missile is broken!
It's broken!
The Stinger missile's broken!
I wish you're so skilled, she can miss with a locked-up
goddamn missile.
Well, I guess no Minto gaming.
But, um, Jeremy, thanks for...
Or, um, I guess thanks.
Whoever, I don't know, actually, who put together the save.
But, um, thanks for gaming.
so I could see the rat.
Completely forgot.
That's not my save.
That's so funny.
All the guided missiles fall.
It actually is, though!
How could I have missed?
There's no way!
I wonder if I could snipe them from maybe down here.
Because...
I don't think I can look up...
Oh, maybe I can't.
Where is he, though?
Hey, Mr. Oh, oh, here he comes, here he comes.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Wait, Mr. Mr. Oh, let's use this.
The cigarettes don't really help so much, but...
Wait, oh, I do have the dyes as a pen.
Never mind, I'm just gonna use that.
Yippee!
What did he drop?
Oh, so...
What's over here?
Nothing new.
Look at Rex!
Oh, ain't she a butte?
Ah, let me in.
Wow!
Look how cool she looks.
Here we go.
Okay.
Pow key time.
Wait, I have...
The gas mask.
Don't really want to get shot at by this guy right here.
Use the gas mask, please.
Jeremy, stop spamming!
Well, I'm gonna save real quick.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Hello.
Be cute.
That's all.
Warhe-sung is toil and trouble.
Honor back and continue back.
What about you, Snake?
Is you all not just an empty bubble, too?
Where is it?
What is...
What have you done to me?
Oh my god.
Wait.
Alright, uh, where's my pal?
Palky.
Wait.
Just put it in.
Alright, there we go.
What about the goggles?
I'll check.
Why is my head so tiny?
Palk code number one.
Confirm.
Yay!
Awaiting Palk code number two.
Okay.
That takes care of Palk code number one.
Now, pal number two, freeze the key.
Freeze the key!
Oh, come on!
What happened to my thing?
It wasn't over.
Um...
Goggles.
Oh my god, it's... Oh, I can't even see anything though.
It's... Oh, it's so... Oh my god, I can't see anything.
It's the same though, it looks like.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Oh, it didn't even get me.
Is this guy still here?
Is this guy back?
Oh my god.
Oh wait.
I'm wrong.
The body armor.
Here, we'll check out.
We'll try everything here, right?
It's so funny.
What's the body armor?
Where is it?
Body.
I try, I actually have the body armor.
Wait, wait.
My hair is green now.
But it's not undoing it.
That's so funny.
Wait, so.
But now my hair's back to normal.
I become a skinny legend.
I become a skinny legend!
Yeah!
Oh my god.
My eyes, please.
Okay.
Anyway.
Slendermint.
There he is.
I think I can shoot him again.
From here?
I missed her.
Where'd you go?
Why can't I find anything?
I think I'm getting hungry, so...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, my goodness.
Oh, my God.
Take the test as a palm.
Please!
Ah!
Don't move so jerkily like...
Oh my god, please.
Did he die?
Yay!
He did.
Let's go freeze a key.
I wish the hot one was first, to be honest.
I wish I could go all the way to the hot...
I would rather go to the hot one first, you know.
He got sniped.
I'm a sniper, I'm like, so close.
Hmm.
Use the cardboard box.
I didn't know he was going to walk over there, though.
Oh, my goodness, my skirt.
Oh, la, la.
Don't look.
How's it going to see?
Yeah, I wish he could pick which key you did first as well.
Yeah, I don't know.
I just don't feel like going all the way to the hot area.
Oh, my God, my skirt!
a little bit.
Wait, what's wrong with me?
Ah, I'm missing the front part of my skirt!
This way.
Uh, no, we're fine here.
It's the other part.
That's the...
Is this... Is it fine right here, actually?
Um, let's get our chaff grenades ready.
Shameless ghost!
This is not me!
realize that there's a way to go over there.
How many...
My health is still fine.
Alright, the PAL key.
Oh my god!
Oh my god.
Card key, PAL key.
I like how the whole thing with the card key is a huge Metal
Gear 2 reference.
You know what's funny is in my short when I was just like,
Like, Metal Gear Solid feels like a remake of Metal Gear 2.
There are people who are just like, um, no.
Metal Gear Solid is its own thing.
And I'm like, I don't think you realize that just like Metal
Gear Solid 2, Metal Gear Solid 1 is also basically a remake.
They took it so literally.
But it is, but like, there's so much, yeah, like, Oh, not
yet, not yet.
There's so much from Metal Gear that they use in Metal Gear
Solid.
Like, it's the same format and everything.
But, what do I know?
I'm just a ghost girl.
They've made the same game three times in a row.
Like, actually!
Maybe, you know...
Oh, it's good, it's good.
Kojima is truly a genius.
You know?
He can make the same game three times and it's fine.
I'm gonna use so many trap grenades here is kind of painful.
He keeps getting away with it.
Are you playing as yourself?
Yeah!
I've always been in the game!
You're actually in the game!
I'm in the game!
I love how people are coming in and being like, Yo!
Go
up, go up, please.
The car, the pal key, still good.
I think it's the red one that we would have to worry about
more, but...
Where's this guy at?
I don't know where he's... where he stands.
I think I can get him from here.
I don't think I can, though.
Where is he at?
I think I can only see his little feet.
From here.
And he's gone.
on it anyway.
I'm just gonna run for it.
Run!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You won't see me, right?
Yeah.
We're good.
Don't worry about it.
This one.
Beep, beep.
There we go.
Okay.
What was that noise?
Oh, okay.
we're gonna save the world you guys we're gonna save the
world we're gonna okay stop that nuclear oh it's floating
next comes pal number three warm the key warm the key all
right snake cheeks open open up Do
you think there's still a...
What's it called?
A, um, an alert.
Do you think there's still an alert?
You think we're good?
Let's go check it out.
We're good!
Okay, let's snipe this guy.
Where's my desert pan?
Oh, if you have a cold?
That's so cute.
Oh, where'd he go?
Hello?
Mr. Come back.
Oh.
Oh, I didn't take this, did I?
Wait, or did I?
You know what?
It's fine.
I'm only gonna have to use it a couple times.
Oh, okay.
Double dose.
I'm just, uh, you know, being cautious.
I'm addicted to the meds.
I need my dizzy Pam!
Take a dip in the Metal Gear soup.
Wait, does that...
No way, that doesn't work.
That doesn't work, does it?
I mean, it's like nuclear waste, doesn't it?
It should work.
Shouldn't it?
Shouldn't it work?
Oh, I went the wrong way.
Oh, that's fine.
Got some more bullets.
Metal Gear acid.
Give me a spoon, I'll test it.
Alright, this way.
I'm actually curious.
But I don't want to, like...
Just got here and I got jump scared by seeing Vince FGS be
real.
Holy shit.
I don't think it works.
That's me.
That's me in the game!
That's me killing Vulcan Raven one shot.
I mean, not one shot.
One first try.
Oh, I do that every time.
It'll still work though, right?
Please work.
Okay.
I just threw it down into the ground!
Oh, I ended up...
Alrighty.
Let's go.
Let's go back to...
oh my god i forgot there's guys here now oh my god sorry
that scared me so much wait i forgot there's guys here now
no way no my my my my my little walk my walk in the park no
okay um i have to remember okay he doesn't see me oh my god
why are there There's so many guys here.
What the hell?
Which way did they go?
I'm not in your way.
I was not in your way.
I was so out of your way.
You don't have to be like this to me.
You don't have to be like this to me, man.
Luckily I was just by the door.
So it all worked out.
I will take this ration.
I will take this one.
Just a mix.
He went out of his way to be in your way.
I know, right!
It doesn't, it's so unfair!
I feel like they pick on me for no reason.
They pick on me.
Hey, crows, come here, I'm gonna punch you.
Come here, oh.
I punched him!
Stream?
No?
It's not on my end.
Wait.
Are we good?
Hmm?
Oh, we're back?
We're back?
Okay, okay, okay.
It scared me.
I was about to type in the chat like, hello?
Now you've got to warm the key up.
Find some place hot.
Hot.
A cake.
Campbell I'm right here now you've got a warm it you need to
find someplace hot why do they all say hot how does Otacon
say it somewhere warm what about the blast furnace but the
problem is if you go through a cold place on the way back
the card key might change shape you need to hurry on the way
back okay that key is an ic card its connector pins and main
body are made of a shape memory alloy cafe espionage it's
designed so that unless it's been changed to the correct
shape it won't be recognized by the pal code input terminal
in the control room and the detonation code won't be entered
okay i'll do my best i am gonna save though real quick what
can i do for you sneak save sorry save and save
Snake, come what come me.
Time and the hour runs through the roughest day.
We're almost out of time, Snake.
I know.
Please hurry.
You're the only one who can stop them from launching that
nuke.
I'm going, I'm going.
I'm going for you.
For you, girl.
Oh, hello?
Oh!
Snake, it's about Naomi Hunter.
Faster.
Then you should talk to the Colonel.
He's looking into it.
Turn your monitor off.
Okay, it's off.
No one else can hear us.
Go ahead.
Sorry, but I didn't want the colonel to hear.
Oh my gosh.
Are you gonna whisper sweeten up things about you?
I've got a good friend in the Pentagon.
Yeah.
He's the one who told me about it.
Okay.
It looks like the DIA recently developed a new type of
assassination weapon.
An assassination weapon?
Snake, have you ever heard of something called Fox Die?
Oh!
Fox Die.
Liquid and the others were talking about it.
No.
It's some kind of virus that targets specific people.
I don't know all the details, but what are you trying to
say?
Yeah, what are you trying to say, huh?
It's too similar.
What is the cause of death?
Didn't the Arms Tech President and the DARPA chief, I mean
Decoy Octopus, die of something that looked like a heart
attack?
Yeah.
Well, apparently Fox die kills its victims by stopping it.
simulating a heart attack what no you're telling me that
Naomi was behind it no snake try to remember did Naomi give
you some kind of injection nanomachines she was in the best
position to have done it but I don't know what her motive
was guys I think I'm in trouble I'm not sure but he still
hasn't questioned her okay I feel the box time flowing
through me Colonel what's new with the Naomi I just placed
Naomi under arrest.
Yippee!
She was sending coded messages towards the Alaskan base.
I didn't want to believe it, but she must be working with
the terrorists.
Are you sure?
I'm afraid so.
She's being interrogated now.
Yeah, get her ass!
What kind of interrogation?
Well, I'd like to avoid the rough stuff, but we don't even
have any of the impenetrable here.
Call me if you find out anything.
Cut off her tongue!
Wait, then she can't tell us anything.
That means the Fox-Dy vaccine must be around somewhere.
Listen, I've got bigger things to worry about.
But Snake, you might be infected too, you know.
All I can do is leave it up to the Colonel.
I'm probably fine.
I'm probably okay.
I'm curious, how fast do I have to go from the hot area to
the cold?
To the, like, you know, like, oh, look at
the carrier, boy.
I think there's a bomb over there, right?
And then there's...
Ah!
What?
I'm in here!
Are you kidding me?
I haven't even moved!
I'm gonna blow this thing up.
Take it out!
Okay.
If I'm really careful...
Oh, come on.
I don't even need it.
There was nothing else in here, though, right?
Okay, good.
Alrighty.
To the heat.
Stop taking injections from random women.
She was...
She was sexy.
The game gives you plenty of time.
Okay, cool.
Ah.
We got all...
Look at the deep darkness.
It's pretty spooky down there.
She was okay.
Damn.
Hey, P.P.
Paladin has some high standards.
I think Naomi is quite attractive.
It's just her personality that really makes it, uh, just
really ruins it, you know.
Otherwise, I think she's a fine-looking gal.
It's just, when she opens her mouth, I'm like, okay, you can
stop now.
That's all.
so gorgeous.
Mei Ling is perfect.
Nothing can...
I'm not saying... It's not like, you know, I'm saying Mei
Ling is prettier than...
than...
Or I'm not saying Naomi's prettier than Mei Ling or
anything.
I'm just saying that...
I'm just saying...
That Naomi's good looking.
But Mei Ling is definitely, you know.
Oh!
Can I go in here?
Alright, we're just gonna chill in here for now.
If I get caught by the steam...
If I get...
If I walk into the steam, that surely should heat it up
more.
I've seen Naomi...
I've seen the May Lake 3D model, but actually I don't think
I've seen the Naomi one.
Technically, not wrong.
in the steam look
there's an item there it's probably more bullets that I
don't need is that solid mint my I'm gonna let it I'm gonna
let it simmer a little bit more I can fix her just a little
bit more it's got to be peak it's got to be peak top tip top
red shape call master Miller what's he gonna say to me so
Naomi's a spy just like I thought Campbell is hiding
something too yeah but that's okay Fox die is a virus a
biological weapon there must be a vaccine We can worry about
getting that later, Snake, but right now you've got to focus
on re-inputting those detonation codes, okay?
He seems really, you're kind of seem a little desperate
there.
I'm in The key changed shape.
Hurry to the control room.
That's the last key Master, I've never heard you so excited.
I was gonna say he seems really excited
Master The key changed shape.
Hurry to the control room.
That's the last key.
Miller, go to Dean's home.
Are you in the boiler room?
Those pipes are really old.
Once in a while, they blow out steam, so be careful.
I've always been careful.
This once in a while.
Snake is so sassy.
Watch out for the steam.
It's dangerous.
Use your first person view.
Oh, the sass!
I love it.
Yeah, I like a sauna now and then, but this is too much.
I love these Kodak clothes.
Alright, I think we're good now.
Wait, what's that?
Is that a rat over there?
Wait, what are the red dots?
Oh no, those are people.
Right?
No, they're not.
What am I seeing?
Anyway, let's just leave.
Okay.
Run, run, run!
Wait, if I put the pal key away, it's better, right?
Technically, I think?
I gotta stuff it in my pants.
Metaphorical rats.
What does that mean?
They're...
Oh no, it's all the nuclear waste here.
Basically just rat people.
Neither true rat, true, or true person.
They are both.
What pants?
You know how girls will keep stuff in their bras?
Like money and stuff?
I've never done that before because I think...
Ah!
Oh my god.
I'm in a hurry, man!
Um...
I'm just gonna run for it.
Perfect.
Let's go.
It's so gross.
People will, like, I've worked retail where, like, some lady
will pull out a $10 bill from her bra, and it's literally
damp.
It's so gross.
It's so nasty.
Because it falls straight through.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Hey, hey.
If you wear a bra, it's not going to fall out.
Gosh, you guys!
Beyblade!
Let her rip!
Go, Mint!
Go, White Girl, go!
Snake, can you hear me?
Naomi?
It's Naomi.
Naomi, what the hell?
I know that British millennial.
Camel and the others are busy right now.
I'm on a different codec.
Naomi, is what the Colonel says true?
Yes.
everything i said was a lie who are you yeah who are you i
don't know myself i don't know my real name or even what my
parents looked like i bought all my identification but my
reason for getting into genetics was true because you want
to know yourself right that's right i want to know where i
came from my age my race anything you're white and british i
was found in rhodesia sometime in the 80s a dirty little
orphan Rhodesia what's now known as Zimbabwe Zimbabwe
Rhodesia was owned by England until 1965 and there were lots
of Indian laborers around that's probably where I got my
skin color from but I'm not even sure about that see even
she says it you're too worried about the past isn't it
enough to understand who you are now understand who I am now
why should I know what else tries to understand me I was
alone for so long until I met my big brother and him him
your big brother yes Frank Jaeger oh what he was a young
soldier oh Frank Jaeger wait a second I was half dead from
starvation Jaeger his rations with me hunter yes Frank
Jaeger the man who you destroyed was my brother and my only
family no no gray fox oh my god we survived that hill
together frank and i jaeger is hunter in german it's my one
connection i never made the connection the only connection i
have to my past and he brought you back to america no no i
was in mosaic when he came who was he you mean big boss yes
he brought us to this land of freedom this America then he
and my brother went back to Africa thank you that's when it
happened you killed my benefactor and sent my brother home a
cripple I vowed revenge and joined Foxhound but I knew it
was my best chance to meet you and I prayed for the day that
I would I was part of Fox Town.
Why would you join Fox Town?
Yes.
I waited two long years.
Shut up, Naomi.
Yeah.
Is that all you cared about?
Did you know that Jaeger is German for Hunter?
What?
Two years.
You were all I thought about for too long.
Gosh, everyone's so obsessed with me.
You still hate me.
Just like Sniper Wolf, just like Naomi.
Everybody's obsessed with the legend.
I was partly wrong about you.
What about Liquid and the others?
I'll have my revenge on them, too.
Naomi, you didn't kill that doctor, too, did you?
The one that used Grey Fox for his genome experiments?
Dr. Clark?
Rent free.
That was my brother.
Afterwards, I covered it up and helped him hide out.
So that ninja, I mean Grey Fox, he's come here to kill me.
think so i think he just came here to fight you i wasn't
sure before but now i think i understand a final battle with
you that's all he lives for i'm sure of it fox no gray fox
Naomi tell me something about fox die fox die is a type of
retro virus that targets and kills only specific people
that's crazy first it infects the macrophage in the victim's
body like that that box dark contains like a virus created
through protein engineering made i mean i know this is a
game but still those enzymes recognize the target's dna
right they respond by becoming active and using the
macrophages they begin creating tnf hello hello it's a type
of cytokine a peptide which causes cells to die the tnf
epsilon is carried along the bloodstream to the heart.
Yon yon, nerd talk, don't you?
Come on, Naomi, pick it up.
They cause a heart attack?
The heart cells suffer a shock and undergo an extreme
apoptosis.
Then the victim dies.
Apoptosis?
You mean the heart cells commit suicide.
Naomi's a...
What?
Naomi's a broken heart?
You must have programmed that thing to kill me too, right?
Oh, oh!
Do I still have time?
Naomi I don't blame you for wanting me dead but I can't go
yet I still have a job to do dumb what about what's the
vaccine though you know like listen snake she just creates
this thing and then doesn't make a vaccine for it decision
to use Fox die you weren't you were injected with Fox die as
a part of this operation I just wanted to let you know that
No, that's not the whole truth.
Come on, Naomi, you compulsive liar, you?
Snake just...
The real thing I wanted to tell you was...
Huh?
Snake, I...
I...
You've fallen in love with me.
Snake!
Snake...
Naomi...
Colonel!
I can't allow Naomi to make any more unauthorized
transmissions.
What?
Naomi's been removed from this operation.
to Naomi.
What did she mean when she said that Fox Die was part of
this operation?
Colonel, let me talk to her.
I won't.
She's under arrest.
Colonel!
You double crossed me.
Yeah.
Snake, there's no time for that.
Right now, your job is to stop Metal Gear.
Colonel is so slimy in this game.
He's so... Oh, he's so... Oh, trying to grab him.
He's so slimy in this game.
I hate it.
All right, we gotta try and get through here, you guys.
We gotta try and get through here without getting detected.
I'm nervous.
Yeah, back to card time.
Okay.
Just run.
Nice.
Thank you.
Okay.
Chaff grenade.
Nice.
Okay.
How's our key looking?
Zoom.
It's quite red for now.
Oh,
I love that angle.
I love the angles that show you how mad Massive Rex's, you
know?
It's so fun.
Mint tomato!
We'll need those later, you guys.
Oh, oh, wrong way, wrong way.
We'll need them later!
Let's put the- Oh!
Peter O'clock virus.
Stop!
Alright.
Run, run, run!
Alright, let's kill him.
this guy maybe?
Maybe I shouldn't kill him.
I think actually...
Wait, where is he?
No, he's not in back.
I think we can just...
go through.
All right.
Our... our... our card is still good?
Okay, nice and nice soon!
Let's uh...
hide from the...
Oh my goodness, please.
There we go.
Oh my god.
Go, go, go, go, go!
And then, I think I can just pal key it up.
There we go!
Yippee!
They don't even need the chaff.
Yay, we saved the world!
Yippee!
detonation code I deactivated it thank you snake now the
detonation code is completed master nothing can stop metal
gear now master what's going on you You found the key and
even activated the warhead force too.
I let the colonel double-cross you, but how could you
double-cross me too?
Sorry to have involved you in that silly shape-memory alloy
business.
Gosh.
What are you talking about?
We weren't able to learn the DARPA chief's code.
The fact that Snake has no idea what's going on this entire
game is just so sad.
How could you...
No!
and kill him during the interrogation.
In other words, we weren't able to launch the nuclear
device, and we were all getting a little worried.
Without the threat of a nuclear strike, our demands would
never be met.
What do you mean?
Without the detonation codes, we had to find some other way.
That's when we decided you might prove useful, Snake.
What?
First, I thought we might get the information from you snake
oh my god so i had decoy octopus disguise himself as the
darpa chief played like a damn fiddle octopus didn't survive
the encounter thanks to fox joy thank you for the big thing
you mean you had this plan from the beginning thank you for
another thank you so much detonation code huh you didn't
think you made it this far by yourself did you what a joke
are you in any case the launch preparations are complete
Once the world glimpses the power of this weapon, the White
House will have no choice but to surrender the Fox-Dyne
vaccine.
To me.
Their ace in the hole is useless now.
No.
What the, the Pentagon's plan to use you was already
successful in the torture room.
Stop laughing.
You're the only one who doesn't know.
Thank you for that 50 gift and thank you.
Who are you anyway?
I'll tell you everything you want to know.
Yes, yes, yes, here we go.
If you come where I am, that is.
Where are you?
Very close by.
Snake, that's not Master Miller.
No shit.
You're too late.
Oh my god, the voice change is so great.
Just discovered at his home.
He's been dead for at least three days.
I didn't know because my codec link with Master was cut off.
You don't confirm these things, Colonel!
was coming from inside the base oh my god so who is it snake
you've been talking to oh my god me dear brother yeah liquid
how the you've served your purpose you may die now no
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Snake, that's bulletproof glass.
You can't break it with an ordinary weapon.
Too sexy for my sunglasses, brother.
Oh my god, please!
Just hold on for a minute.
Okay, I don't have a minute!
Oh wow, for Kazuhiro Miller.
I know right.
I don't trust him and hang on.
Okay.
I'm trust- I don't trust you though.
Master!
Why is my- It's so small.
Oh, there's rations in here.
My head.
I look like a...
I look like a bean.
Like a pea head.
Snake, I'm opening the door.
Thanks, Otakon!
Yippee!
Oh, I gave you another ration even.
I was just like, hey.
You're not feeling so well.
Oh my god.
It's actually maybe one of my favorite parts of the game.
I'm not going to lie.
Do you guys mind if I can get some food before the Rex
fight?
So I can eat while I am, while Liquid is doing his little
monologuing.
So I'm going to go grab some food real quick.
I'll be fast because I don't have to heal.
I'll be right back.
I'll be like just a few.
back on
back on back sorry about that all right hold on i have to
move a little bit of stuff okay all right don't spill it oh
don't spill it okay there we go welcome back thank you thank
you thank you guys all right we ready for let's go time for
me to eat
Wow, that's a whole lot of liquid.
Really, you just baited me so much.
Oh, I'm still gone fishing.
There we go.
Dang, look at his abs.
This guy never has a shirt on.
It's Alaska.
What are you showing off for?
Liquid!
Snake!
Did you like my sunglasses?
Liquid!
Whoa!
You point a weapon at your own, brother?
Why did you disguise yourself as master?
So I could manipulate you more easily.
And you performed quite well, I must say.
Although the boys at the Pentagon are probably saying the
same thing.
What the hell are you talking about?
Following orders blindly, with no questions asked, you've
lost your warrior's pride and become nothing more than a
palm snake.
Pickled out.
Stopping the nuclear launch, rescuing the hostages.
it was all just a diversion a diversion the Pentagon only
needed for you to come into contact with us that's what
killed the arms tech president and decoy octopals you don't
mean that's right you were sent here to kill us so they
could retrieve metal gear undamaged along with the bodies of
the genomes soldiers from the beginning the Pentagon was
just using you as a vector to spread Fox die Fox die it
can't be are you telling me Naomi was working with the
Pentagon they thought she was but it seems that dr. Naomi
hunter couldn't be controlled so easily everybody's a
double-crosser we've got a spy working in the Pentagon he
reported that dr. hunter altered Fox dies program just
before the operation but no one knows how why because she's
crazy maybe they arrested her so they could find out the
answer to that no doubt but I had no idea she was motivated
by such petty revenge we still don't know what changes she
made to Fox die's program oh well it doesn't matter I've
already added the Fox die vaccine to my list of White House
demands there's a vaccine but if she changed it that woman
is the only one who really knows if she changed it then it
doesn't you know anyway it might prove to be unnecessary why
that you were successful in coming into contact with all of
us so we must have all been exposed to the virus it's true
that the arms tech president and decoy octopus were killed
by Fox die but Ocelot myself and you the carrier were
apparently unaffected a bug in the viruses programming could
be in any case if it doesn't kill you I'm not talking a lot
I'm not worried after all our genetic code is identical so
it's true you and i are yes twins but we're not ordinary
twins we're twins linked by cursed genes genes they're so
far terrible you're fine dominant genes i got the flawed
recessive genes everything was done so that you would be the
greatest of his children i got the you I was the favorite
huh that's right I'm just the leftovers of what they used to
make you can you understand what it's like to know that your
garbage since the day you were born but I'm the one father
chose so that's why you're so obsessed with big boss some
warped kind of love love it's hate he always told me I
inferior and now I'll have my revenge you should understand
I can't imagine him saying that you know you killed our
father with your own hands I just can't imagine him being
like hey inferior brother over there now I'll finish the
work that father began I will surpass him I will destroy him
you're just like Naomi well I'm not like you I'm not like
you Uh-oh, is it time?
It's close to time.
Snake, your blood will be the first to be filled by this
glorious new weapon.
Yeah.
Consider it an honor, a gift from your brother.
Now I'll show you the power of your weapon that will lead us
in the 21st century.
Okay, I got my controller.
I put away my food.
It's moving.
I wonder how I'm gonna do on the...
I'm on the first fight.
You're locked in.
How do I stop it?
Ta-da!
Here we go.
Wow, it looks so awesome.
Guys, I'm getting a stomach ache already.
Immediately?
Body armor.
Immediately, trap grenades.
Run!
What
the hell?
Oh my god.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
What are you doing?
Okay, hold on.
That's not what I meant to do.
I meant to call Otakun.
Snake, Rex's armor is impregnable.
You can't do any damage with the weapons you've got.
What do I do?
Rex uses the latest advances in compound armor.
The only way you can pierce it is with a high performance-
White stem!
Rex's pilot seat operates exactly like a...
VR system.
It's got multiple sensors connected to a high-tech interface
used for the controls.
It's completely self-enclosed and shut off from the outside
environment.
Okay.
He's not using his naked eyes.
Naked eyes.
That's right.
So if you could somehow destroy the sensors, do you see that
round plate on Rex's left arm?
Yeah.
That thing that looks like a shield.
That's a ray dome.
If you can destroy that thing, it won't be able to use its
electronic equipment.
Alright.
So you'll be blinded.
Yeah.
Try to hit that ray dome with a Stinger missile.
Stinger missile.
No.
Rex was designed so it can be controlled manually too.
I already threw the chat.
The Raidome.
Rex's armor is perfect.
You can't destroy it.
Oh, look at it.
You told me that already.
But the interior is a different story.
Ah.
I get it.
First I destroy the Raidome.
The Raidome.
That will force him to open up the pilot's seat.
Right.
As much as I hate to acknowledge MGS5, the implication is
that it's how Liquid felt rather than the reality.
It's not a weak point.
It's like a plant.
I like to think of it as a character flaw.
Character flaw.
People just aren't complete without some type of character
flaw, don't you think?
I guess so.
I owe you one Otacon.
Okay.
I will say, I know it's probably pointless.
Snake does nothing I can do to help you.
All I can do is cheer you on.
I know it's kind of pointless, but I am going to save.
We will save because, you know, what if like something
crashes right right okay don't give up don't give up i'm
scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared i'm scared guys
guys is not good not good not good start not good start not
good start not good start not good start okay okay okay okay
stinger explode please Did I even throw it?
I don't think I threw the chap grenade.
There we go.
Okay, I'm gonna really concentrate on this part.
Ow!
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh god, oh god.
Ah.
Please!
My body armor, I gotta equip it.
Okay.
They could still seek me out so easily.
Snake,
what happened?
Snake!
We have Zanzibar counter!
Why?
We haven't even hit Zanzibar!
It's okay, we started off really bad, so...
Can I skip this part?
Okay, there we go.
Alright.
Oh.
God,
I don't have my anything on.
Oh,
I did a stun grenade.
I'm such an idiot.
Run!
Oh my god.
Ah!
Wait.
Sorry.
I'm just concentrating really much.
The time, actually.
Even the time.
Okay.
Oh no, here it comes.
My sword.
Snake.
Woo!
Hurry!
Rip it off!
Grey Fox!
It's a long ago.
It sounds better than Deep Throne.
He was Deep Throne!
This is a terrible snake.
You haven't aged well.
I'll send you back to hell!
Grey Fox!
Fox, why?
What do you want from me?
I'm a prisoner of death.
Only you can free me.
Aww.
box stay out of this what about Naomi she's hell-bent on
taking revenge for you Naomi you're the only one who could
stop her no I can why because I'm the one who killed her
parents I was young then and couldn't bring myself to kill
her too I felt so I raised her like she was my own blood to
soothe my guilty conscience of me as our brother marks on
the outside we might have seemed like a happy brother and
sister but every time I looked at her I saw her parents eyes
staring back at me tell her for me tell her that I was the
one who did it I'll tell her we're just about out of time
here's the final present From deep throat.
Oh, yeah.
I'll stop it from moving But But No Is
that exoskeleton of yours?
Snake, are you just going to sit by and watch him die?
Oh boy
Corna Fox is more dangerous than a jackal Yeah Destroy the
radio No, I can't do it I can't do it.
No, I can't do it.
Impressive!
You are indeed worthy of the code name Fox, but now you're
finished!
No!
Fire the Stinger!
Can you really shoot?
You'll kill him too!
Now...
I was taken from the battle.
Neither truly alive, nor truly dead.
I can't do it.
In a world of light.
Just put him out, just do it.
But soon, there's no good.
Soon, it will finally end.
No, we can't do it.
After Zanzibar.
Die!
I was...
No!
We're not tools of the government.
I love this part.
For anyone else.
Fighting was the only thing.
The only thing I was good at.
But...
At least I always fought for what I believed in.
Snake, farewell.
Foolish man!
Death, and it found him.
You see, you can't protect anyone, not even yourself.
Die!
Okay.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, chill, chill, chill, man.
Chill, chill, chill.
All right, hold on.
I'm hyping myself up, mentally.
Ooh, those hit.
Can I get him from here?
Am I too close?
Oh.
Ah, shit.
I'm too close.
I didn't miss.
I didn't make it.
Okay, uh, oh.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Sorry.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit, you guys.
I'm getting lost in the sauce a little bit.
Okay, we just gotta do the same thing.
But, oh my god.
You were too close?
Ah!
Shit, shit, shit, shit.
I thought I had the stun grenades opened.
These do work, right?
Like...
Okay.
Alright.
Stop!
You are not supposed to see me!
The
whole stinger to the face.
It's crazy.
Shouldn't it be the chaff?
No, it's not the chaff because the ray dome is done.
Now he's looking with his eyes.
Give
me more rushes.
Why doesn't it work as well?
Like the chaff is for sure to work, but this like doesn't...
I just can't get the timing of it right.
Ah, chill out!
You jerk!
Oh, no.
Oh shit, I'm gonna die.
Oh,
this is not it.
Oh, oh,
Oh man.
Oh,
it's close though.
Oh, it's close.
Why
are his eyes so much better like than Then, when he's using
the VR, huh?
That's my question.
Why do his eyes work?
Oh, hello?
Oh my god, I just put down a C4.
I'm such an idiot.
Wait, did I even throw this?
Why do his eyes work better?
When he's...
When he's not used inside the thing!
180 IQ?
I guess so.
Oh
my god, I just realized.
Rushing.
Ah!
Healthy, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, out, out.
Ouch, out, out, out, out.
Um...
Like, this part, I can pretty much get down easy.
Ouch, out.
I say that.
I should have, hold on.
Um, as soon as I shoot this, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna put on the body armor.
Or I'm gonna heal.
Put on the body armor instead.
Did I throw another shaft?
If not, I'm just
gonna throw another one just in case.
Okay, let's do it.
Yeah, respect people's boundaries, exactly!
Did that do it?
Try getting behind him in phase two.
Does that actually work?
Try.
Oh wait, I'm gonna skip this, I'm sorry.
Because this is the- Now, in front of
you, nor do you mean that.
An undying shadow in a world of-
This phase two always gets me, man.
Look at him up there in the corner!
Ugh, I haven't even made a single hit.
You guys!
How
do I get to him?
How do I get to him?
Hey!
Turn around, idiot!
Look for me, I'm a lost cause.
Don't look for me.
Thank you guys.
I remember.
Oh, shoot.
Don't look for me.
Why does he just stand there?
Ouch!
Gun!
When you think of it that way, it's so much easier.
Stop
it when you're gonna crush me.
Wait, I think I'm facing...
Oh no, I'm facing the right way.
Don't see me, don't see me, don't see me.
Yeah, you don't know.
Don't get crushed, don't get crushed, Snake.
Yeah!
Go between his legs.
He's antsy.
He is antsy.
Come on, come on, come here.
I'm gonna try it.
Nice!
Soundgun!
Well, he lost track of me anyway.
What a dummy.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Okay, maybe I can get it in.
Maybe I can get it in.
You're too close.
You're too much on me, okay?
You're too obsessed with me.
I'm telling you.
Oh my god, oh my god.
Could you not do that?
Sir, stun gun.
Stun gun.
Stop walking backwards.
Okay, I'll see you later.
Oh my god, don't blow it up.
Don't blow it up.
Stop.
Stop liquid!
You're gonna blow it up!
Stop!
I'm right here!
Right here!
Please!
Please,
liquid, please!
Please, liquid, please!
You're being too erratic!
You're scaring me!
Yeah!
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god!
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch.
It's okay.
Oh, gosh.
Wait, maybe it's not okay.
It's okay.
No, you don't!
You don't see me!
I'm a go!
I'll
crush you into dust
How could she miss?
Come grab me, brother Oh, panties No Oh my god How are you
still alive?
How?
You've taken so many so many stinger missiles to the to the
butt i was gonna say to the face but i literally went
underneath you lost a stack thanks for the 10 gifted a snake
liquid what do you mean like as usual you don't know me i
won't die as long as you still live okay good i can eat some
more it looks like your revolution was a failure just
because you've destroyed metal gear doesn't mean guys i got
it in three tries fighting after a world where warriors like
us are honored the length of this stream is how long it used
to take me that was big boss's fantasy it was his dying wish
when he was young during the cold war the world needed men
like us we were valued then we were desired but things oh
are different we were desired i'm still desired what are you
talking about hypocrites running the world war isn't it used
to be war we are losing our place in a world that no longer
needs us a world that now spurs our very existence you
should know that as well as i do after i launch this weapon
and get our billion dollars we'll be able to bring chaos and
they'd stop making these metal gear machines after a show
time and time again one man or one maid can take them out
conflict will breed conflict new hatreds will arise then
we'll steadily our sphere of influence but as long as there
are people there will always be war I'm my first vlog coming
out tomorrow father knew what type of a balance was best is
that the only reason isn't it reason enough for warriors
such as us I don't want that kind of world you lie so why
are you here then why do you continue to follow your orders
while your superiors betray you why did you come here well
i'll tell you then oh say it come on enjoy the killing
that's what are you denying it haven't you already killed
most of my i'm sorry i can't get the twin snakes version out
of my head when he's like up in your face about it your face
when you did it it was filled with the joy a battle you're
wrong there's a killer inside we need an applause emote for
a moment you don't have to deny it thank you we were created
to be that way created let's not applause yet though i still
have one more battle the terrible children that's what the
project was called it started in the 1970s their plan was to
artificially create the most powerful soldier possible the
person that they chose as the model was the man known then
as the greatest living soldier in the world big boss father
was wounded in combat and already in a coma when they
brought him in so they created us from his cells with a
combination of 20th century analog cloning and the super
baby man super baby they fertilized an egg with one of
father's I like how even Snake is just like super baby Then
they transferred the clones to someone's uterus and later
intentionally aborted six of the fetuses to encourage strong
fetal growth Yeah, eat the fetus eat each other in the womb
AAAAAAAA The other six of our brothers were sacrificed to
make us I look like I was going through the super baby
method AAAAAAAA stop The day we were even born So it was you
and I two fertilized eggs with exactly the same DNA.
Minto, close your legs!
They used me as a guinea pig to create a phenotype in which
all of the dominant genes were expressed to create you.
I got all of the recessive genes.
You took everything from me before I was even born.
Super baby Minto.
Super baby.
You and I aren't his only children.
What?
The genome soldiers.
They tour his progeny, carrying on his genetic legacy.
My god, divert your eyes.
Freak phantom stuff!
With the completion of the human genome project, sometimes
the sound, the background noise stops, and sometimes it
comes back.
Real footage.
Thanks to father's DNA, they were able to identify more than
60 soldier genes responsible for everything from Strategic
thinking to the proverbial killer instinct.
Those soldier genes were transplanted into the members of
the next generation special forces.
There's Naomi.
That's how they became the genome soldiers.
That's right.
It's time for the super babies.
The genome soldiers that you've been killing are our
brothers.
Oh my god.
That's my dad.
The genome soldiers.
That's right.
They are our brothers.
I'm so embarrassed of looking at my spread legs.
Ah!
They too are the product of numerous sacrifices.
Sacrifice?
Human experiments!
I can't!
I can't pay attention at all.
The military secretly injected soldiers with the soldier
genes.
The Gulf War syndrome that hundreds of thousands of...
Ooh, Top Gun!
soldiers complained about was a side effect of it ah
everyone knows that the gulf war syndrome was caused by
exposure to depleted uranium used in the anti-tank rounds
babies baby juice that was just a cover story issued by the
pentagon first they tried to say it was post-traumatic
stress look how fast he's going then chemical or biological
weapons the poison gas detection units and the anti-seren
injections they were all just a cover-up of the secret
genetic experiments.
Money for Pan.
So then, the so-called Gulf War babies that have been
reported by Gulf War veterans are...
Us.
They too are our brothers and sisters.
Our brothers and sisters!
So the genome soldiers mean that the experiments were a
success?
Success?
Don't be a fool!
They're a complete failure!
We are on the verge of extinction!
Oh my god, no!
But you have so many genome soldiers here!
Have you ever heard of the asymmetry theory?
Nature tends to favor asymmetry.
Those species which have gone extinct all show signs of
symmetry.
The genome soldiers suffer from the same problem.
Oh my god.
Signs of symmetry.
This angle.
So do I.
As do you.
Oh my god.
That's right.
We are all on the verge of death at the genetic level.
We don't know where, what type of disease will occur that's
why we need the old man's genetic information you want big
boss's dna so you can save your family it's very touching in
nature family members don't mate with each other and yet
they help each other to survive do you know why it increases
the chance that their genes will be passed on to a new
generation all tourism among blood relatives is a response
to natural selection it's called the giant like horn coming
out of That's like censoring everything.
You're telling me that your genes are ordering you to save
the genome soldiers.
You can't fight your genes.
It's fate.
All living things are born for the sole purpose of passing
on their parents' genes.
Jeans, genes, genes.
That's why I'll follow what my genes tell me.
Don't take a shot every time he says genes, you guys.
He'll die.
In order to break the curse of my heritage.
At least her shirt is still on.
And to do that, first, I will kill you.
No!
Okay.
Look behind you.
Oh, Marl!
Marl!
Is she alive?
I'm not sure.
She was alive a few hours ago.
Oh, boy.
Poor girl kept calling your name.
Oh, no.
Marl.
Stupid woman.
Falling in love with a man who doesn't even have a name.
name no we have no past no future and even if we did it
wouldn't be truly ours you and i are just copies of our
father big boss let merrill go as soon as we finished our
business we're almost out of time we're talking about fox
time whoa it seems now that the pentagon knows that mental
gear is destroyed that was so fast they've arrived at a
decision how do they know that I'm huge next to him.
If you want the details, why don't you ask your precious
Colonel Campbell?
I look like, I look like I'm like...
Colonel, can you hear me?
Yes, I'm listening.
What is the Pentagon trying to do?
I'm so mad.
Colonel, answer me.
The Secretary of Defense has taken over active control of
this operation.
He's on his way there by AWACS.
AWACS.
What for?
To bomb the place.
No!
What?
Not only that.
B-2 bombers just lifted off from Galena Air Force Base.
Why didn't you stop, though?
They're carrying B-61-13 surface-piercing tactical nuclear
bombs.
What?
Metal Gear is destroyed.
Tell the Secretary of Defense.
The Secretary of Defense heard that Naomi double-crossed us,
and he's worried about Fox dying.
Now that there's no more danger of a nuclear strike from
Metal Gear, he's going to do whatever's necessary to cover
up the truth of what really happened here.
bomb to vaporize all the evidence along with anyone who
knows anything yeah don't worry snake I'll stop the nuclear
strike okay I trust you I may only be a figurehead here but
I'm still officially in command of this mission not anymore
if I issue an order to delay the strike it'll confuse the
chain of command and at least buy you some time okay give
you a chance to escape but Colonel if you do that it's okay
snake the truth is Foxhound was already the subject of an
undercover investigation.
Meryl was transferred to this base just before the terrorist
attack as a way of manipulating me.
Okay, I believe you.
Those bastards.
I'm sorry.
They forced me to cooperate in exchange for her life.
You better get out of there, Snake.
Are you sure?
They forced you, Colonel.
You could have told me at any time.
It's the least I can do for you after all the lies.
Colonel.
I'm ordering them to cancel the bombing run.
Castle, castle.
After that, there's no turning back.
What?
What are you doing?
Colonel!
Uh-oh.
Snake!
Mealing, what happened to the Colonel?
I don't believe it.
What happened?
Snake, the Colonel!
Roy Campbell has been relieved of the beauty.
This is the Secretary of Defense.
Jim Howdy.
We'll put the Colonel back on.
He's been placed under arrest for leaking top secret
information.
Abraham Lincoln.
Ridiculous.
Yes, he's a ridiculous man.
Oh, I can't wait for that Metal Gear guy.
Ridiculous man.
Hot cold man.
Jim Housman.
Real ridiculous man.
Ridiculous man.
I'm sure the president would want the same thing.
The president ordered this.
The president is a busy man.
I have complete authority here.
Die hard.
Running man.
Bo-Jack Horseman!
We've prepared a convincing cover story.
We'll simply say that the terrorists exploded a nuclear
device.
Don't- don't compliment him.
The scientists, the genome army, everyone.
He's thinking of the scientists.
The DARPA chief is already dead.
So you didn't need to kill the DARPA chief after all.
The houseman plays Campbell under house arrest.
You could care less about what happens to everybody else,
huh?
if you give me the optic disc i might consider saving them
what are you talking about metal gears test data donald was
supposed to bring it back i don't have it i see oh well
that's okay you two are an embarrassment from the 1970s i
hate how mean everybody is to them dirty little secret you
can't be allowed to live well the bombs will be dropping
soon and you two have a lot of catching up to do.
They're so mean.
They're like they asked to be born like this.
Well, that's mean.
There's no way out for us.
We gotta duke it out.
Let's finish this before the airstrike.
Oh, boy.
This is the part I'm scared of, too.
Everything since Vulcan Raven, I've been scared of.
You can store everything for me.
Only your death can save.
satisfy me.
Only your death can return to me what is rightly mine.
Stop looking at her like that, you weirdo.
She'll make a beautiful sacrifice for our final battle.
Which ending are we getting?
I'll be honest.
I don't know.
It will be the time limit for our final battle.
I honestly have no idea.
This nuclear module is set to detonate at the precise moment
of her death.
No!
I was aiming for the Meryl ending because, you know, it's
the canonic canon.
Oh, no, no, no.
Turn on!
My controller turned off.
You could enjoy one brief moment of love before the end.
Oh, my God.
If you cross this line, you fall.
Yeah.
At this height, it will kill even you.
Even you.
Okay.
Come on, let me find him already, please!
Why do they even start- Why do they even start it at a- Oh.
Don't charge.
Yeah.
What's wrong, Snake?
Oh, shoot.
Yeah, I got him.
I got him, no.
Yeah, try running.
Oh, why did I do that?
Why did I do that?
Ah!
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Why does he hit so much more than this?
So unfair.
Come on.
Oh, dang, that was my...
That was my shot when he started running around.
No, no.
I won't let you.
Yeah!
Yeah.
Don't charge.
Why did I do that?
Come up!
There's not a good way for me to...
Oh my god!
Please!
I don't think I can under...
I don't think I...
Oh my god.
I think the size is actually maybe throwing me off a little
bit because I'm like kind of huge.
You know?
Don't charge at me.
I tried to avoid it.
What's wrong, Snake?
Ouch!
Ouch, ow, ow, ow.
Don't charge at me.
Yeah.
Why
can't?
No one cries for me.
No, what if the liquid's just really short?
Short king.
Have at you, Snake.
These stupid iframes.
Okay.
Oh!
Running away, are you?
You coward brother!
I hate.
This isn't ZQC.
This is unfairness.
Why does he hit, like, three times harder than I do?
What's wrong, Snake?
You hit too hard!
That's what's wrong.
That's my problem, man.
That's my problem!
Ah!
Why did that not hit you at all?
Why can I only get one hit in?
Yeah.
What's wrong, Snake?
You're the one running!
Nice shot!
Hurry, it's going to blow!
Oh my god, why did you why did you charge at me twice in a
row?
What?
Oh my god You guys this will be the longest fight I think
this is I don't even think I know I know this is going to be
This is this is the longest this is always the one that gets
me Well, I say that This feels so unfair.
I know right it really is it's it's literally just a get
good, but he has so His iframes last forever?
I think there's a way to like...
There's a way to like pin him and like get him kind of...
Hello?
Go up?
Kind of get him in like a...
in like a 1-2, 1-2, 1-2 you know?
Yeah.
But I just...
But he...
1-2.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh, oh.
One, two.
Yeah.
I'm not doing enough damage.
This sucks, man.
This sucks so much.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
And I'm huge.
Are you gonna dodge it?
Oh
my...
Yeah, that's right.
Try.
Ah!
How did he get me every time?
It's so hard to avoid a stupid dodge.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I gotta get him in like the corner of Rex.
But I don't know.
I'm not skilled enough to be...
It's actually...
It's actually a skill issue.
I'm like actually not skilled enough to do it, I think.
Oh!
You're out of time!
I'm out of life!
That's more like it!
I think he tapped me!
Well, remember what Miller said?
a CQB, which it's harder.
Why did it, why did, why wouldn't, why didn't dad teach a
CQB?
Why is a big boss here hate us?
Why is he hate us?
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Why is he hate us?
Why does he hate us?
What's up, Snake?
I try, I like spam the button to be able to get in enough
hits before the iframes kick in.
But...
But then this happens!
Stop it.
Yeah.
Don't charge.
Oh, did that hurt me for real?
I hate fighting you!
I'm...
This is Mint's Elden Ring.
Do throws not work on him?
No, they don't.
See?
Oh, see, like here.
One, two, one, two.
Then he gets me.
I don't know what, like the angle or anything that he needs
to be in in the court.
I have no idea.
So I'm not even going to attempt.
See, like here is perfect.
And then you, one, two, one.
But I just can't.
I can't get to him.
Get away!
I mean, just...
Die!
Just die!
Why are you like... Why are you like this?
Oh, sorry, my bad.
We're fine.
Adam!
I think, like, out of the whole game, I know this is...
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize we were at that point already.
This is definitely my least favorite fight in the whole
game.
Because it just feels very unfair.
It feels so unfair.
Because he's so manic!
He's so freaking manic!
Oh my god.
It's all- it's everything.
It's how hard he hits.
It's- it's the time limit.
It's just everything that is so hard for me.
I know next hit is gonna kill me.
See?
It's not even the final boss!
Why did he get eye frames there?
Oh my god.
Oh.
That was the furthest I think I've gotten, though.
Have at you, Snake.
I need to learn, though.
The speedrunner way, you know?
Ah!
Oh, you were- that hit you.
That hit, yeah, just like that.
Stop running!
Yeah!
Why are you running?
Bitch.
Oh, oh, damn it.
Nice.
I don't know how sometimes I make that.
Sometimes I don't.
I have no idea.
I just let it happen.
I just...
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
ouch!
Why can't I give more?
Hits it!
It's so weird sometimes.
Oh my god.
Like, even if I do the one two, I only get the one in.
Oh, snake.
There's...
Oh my god.
Ah!
Hi,
that's right!
Oh, shoot.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
God, oh my god, please.
Come on, come on, come on!
Get up!
Oh my god.
I'll see, I'll see, I'll see.
Oh shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit, shit.
I know!
You're not helping!
Get up, get up, get up, get up, get up!
Please.
Oh my god.
Ah!
You are so unfair, Liquid.
You are so unfair!
Oh my god!
Oh, that was genuinely a great attempt, Man.
Good job.
I was, I really was doing well in the beginning too.
Like I had no, no hits for a while.
Which was great.
Oh.
This little bitch.
Words hit.
This makes no sense.
World!
Well, maybe not that.
That's a bit of a dramatic dramatization.
But, oh, but you know what I mean.
He's got them long legs.
Look at me though!
Ouch!
Look at my legs though.
They're much longer.
I'm way more agile.
I'm way more agile than this nerd it's
so hard to read him it's so hard to read when he's gonna
charge at me I
wasn't sure if he was gonna hit me so I oh my god I have
iframes too let me use them oh my god
don't hit me twice it's so unfair
Okay.
I'm out of patience.
That's more what I'm out of.
I'm out of patience!
Stop hitting me twice!
Can anyone explain to me why sometimes my hits don't land
and sometimes...
Is it because I'm too far away?
Is that the issue?
Why are you running?
See you!
I think it's when he's blocking.
How can you tell though?
wrong angle too far away bad angle you died again no fucking
shit me this is the fight I'm worst at in the game anybody
surprised by that hands
can't reach catch these hands so I just got to get real
close on him.
I just gotta be like, Hey, baby girl!
Oh!
Damn, or not like that.
Why sometimes he gets iframes after one hit in phase two?
He frequently gets that and a free counter-attack in that
phase.
He generally will not if you hit him after and does a move
of his own.
Wait, so...
Wait, what?
I thought that was it.
I think I didn't understand.
That's okay.
You tried helping.
I appreciate it.
Oh!
Whoopsie!
Get up.
Please don't.
Please don't charge me.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll get him eventually, though, guys.
Oh, God.
See, there he goes again.
Yeah.
We just run around!
Are you gonna charge at me?
I felt like he was gonna charge at me.
There we go.
get up liquid oh why are you phase through the ground a
little bit
and i know he kicks over
told you we'd get him eventually first try baby
okay we're in the home stretch everybody.
Uh oh.
Ah!
Meryl!
I didn't submit!
Damn!
I have to be on the planet without a god.
I sold your life to save my own.
It's the nerd ending.
I'm a loser.
I'm not the hero For anybody who's joined later I'm nothing
This is not the original save that I started from Basically
I started with the normal game I'm sorry I started with the
normal game And I did not submit I made it through the
torture But To play the mint model I couldn't do it on the
master collection So instead they gave me a save That had
the model in there Yes, blaming yourself makes it easier.
And then, um, and so I wasn't sure.
The save started me at Vulcan Raven, so I wasn't sure if...
Merrill's dead!
Which one we would give?
So, are you going to stay here and die?
Along with her?
So anybody who came in late and was curious about why...
Snake.
I was like, which one are we going to get?
It's gotcha.
Damn.
But death is not...
Damn, a lot of going on.
Dang, I kind of wanted to have the canon ending though.
But it's okay.
Jeremy did this on purpose.
She and I will be together forever.
We didn't lose anything.
Together forever.
This is the canon ending.
But our love didn't end with her.
Life's more than just a game of winning moves.
Oh my god, Otakon is consoling me.
Look at Otakon, he's consoling me.
There's a parking garage right next door.
We can get to the surface from there.
Can you imagine parking right next to Rex?
Come on.
Oh my god, Merrill is so tiny.
It'll be okay.
Meryl's so tiny.
Jeremy's like this.
You have my word on it.
This is the canon ending for Solid Mint.
I'm through regretting the past.
Life isn't all about loss, you know.
Oh, God.
You've changed.
It started.
Ooh.
Those guys.
Seems like they only hurry when they're destroying things.
one true parent good let him destroy it hey they can't
destroy the human spirit I also prefer this ending but you
know okay let's go
let's go it's jiggling or it's like vibrating on my could
have had the G okay did any of you use the G shut up the
GOGF is so unstable It's cold outside.
You'll freeze like that.
What if I would have had no cutscenes or something, you
know?
You'd better hurry.
Put on my sneaky suit.
It's vibrating against my thigh.
It feels nice.
Like a massage.
Now you look like yourself again.
I didn't change anything.
Oh, sorry, I have my little cat mouth now.
I'm more smug.
Pearl had beer o'clock.
Call me, go!
Alrighty.
Awesome.
Hurry!
I'm going, I'm going.
Oh, isn't there some stuff here?
Yeah.
Oh, I only have one ration.
I lost all my stuff.
Oh, come on.
Let's go.
I'll drive.
Don't alert the guards.
Oh.
Why did you do that?
Otakon!
Where's the gun?
Otakon, where's the gun?
Oh my God.
Let's go.
Okay.
I think I forgot to get...
There wasn't there a second ration?
Uh-oh.
Then we have to redo it, it's fine.
Can I...
I'm ready to do it!
I'm ready to shoot him!
I'm ready to mow him down!
Yeah!
Here, wait, which way does he lose him?
Maybe this way.
I'm trying!
These guys can eat bullets!
Was that the last one?
There we go.
Okay.
Don't get it, Snake!
It's not over yet!
Liquid!
Where's my body armor, huh?
I had all my stuff.
What did you do with my stuff, you stealer?
You stole my stuff!
Oh, ouch.
Oh, my God.
You thief!
You're such a thief!
Oh, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh, my God.
Why'd you steal my sum, Liquid, you jerk?
Yeah!
Take him down!
Alar, Olycha!
I'm hitting you!
Yeah!
Yeah, I'm ready for this big boss rank.
Are you okay?
I guess so.
Otacon, can you move?
It's embarrassing.
I'm a skirt.
It's no use.
I can't move.
What happened to Liquid?
I don't know.
But I hope he's dead.
Thank you for this never done it.
Liquid's dead.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
Look at me!
Snake!
He hates anime!
Die!
Jenna!
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh!
My waifu!
Yeah!
Now he's dead!
Woohoo!
If he's dead, that means...
Oh, oh wait, that means about me?
Oh no.
Don't think about it, Snake.
Aww.
What happened to the air raid?
No stealth bombers in sight.
Snake, can you hear me?
Colonel, are you okay?
Actually, this ending is better because The Secretary of
Defense gets to be with anime.
Early retirement.
It works.
Arrested.
I was able to get into contact with the President.
Oh, nice.
Metal gear, the training exercise, all of it.
It was all the Secretary of Defense acting alone.
Acting alone?
What happened to the air raid and the nuclear strike?
We called it off.
The orders were rescinded.
The F-117s and the B-2 spirits have returned to the base.
Everything's good!
I have complete authority over this operation.
Colonel.
I see.
Washington isn't stupid enough to use nukes to cover up a
few secrets.
I wonder about that.
Yeah, I do too.
In any case, the danger's over.
Yeah.
Thanks, Snake.
About Merrill.
I already know.
Colonel.
Merrill was my daughter.
What?
We killed his daughter!
I didn't find out until recently.
I got a letter from her mother, my dead brother's wife.
I was going to tell her after this operation was over.
Uh-oh.
Colonel, I...
It's okay, Snake.
Thanks anyway.
Oh!
Snake, I'm sorry.
I kept a lot of things from you.
It's okay, Colonel.
Are you always fated to get the Otacon ending?
I'm not a Colonel.
Okay, Colonel.
I've got a present for you.
I actually like Meryl.
You should be able to ride right out of there.
I'll bet the boys at the DIA and the NSA never expect you to
come home alive.
Me neither.
I better not show my face around here.
No danger of that.
You two officially died after your jeep sank into the ocean.
That's not too far from the truth.
Also, there's a helicopter waiting for you on Fox Island.
Fox Island.
Okay, Roy.
Are you gonna be okay?
Don't worry.
I've got an insurance policy.
A hard copy of all Mei Ling's data.
As long as I've got that, you, me, and Mei Ling will be
fine.
Mei Ling's saving the day.
That's my girl!
They won't be able to follow us.
I guess we won't meet again.
Don't worry.
I'll pay you a visit sometime.
Really?
I look forward to that.
Roy.
just tell me one thing what about fox die yeah what about me
it killed liquid it killed like Naomi said that she wants to
talk to you face to face about that how is she don't worry
Mei Ling is with her right now I'm switching over to Naomi I
need to learn to be more like snake it's me Naomi he doesn't
think that Naomi is so annoying I'm sorry but he had one
last message he wanted to say to you.
He told me to tell you to forget about him and to go on with
your own life.
You're such a good person.
Frankie said that?
Yeah.
You're such a good guy.
He also said he'll always love you.
Naomi, your brother just saved you, me, and the whole world.
She doesn't deserve those nice lies.
He fought with every ounce of strength in his body.
She doesn't deserve it.
She's such a good guy.
he's finally found some peace he wasn't really my brother
anymore ever since he fought with you in zanzibar he's been
like a ghost a ghost looking for a place to die
okay shut up naomi liquid died from fox died too yeah it's
kind of important When am I gonna go?
That's up to you.
What do you mean?
Everybody dies when their time is up.
Yeah, but Naomi, I have a virus in me.
So when's mine up?
Naomi.
It's up to you how you use the time left to you.
No, this is...
Live, Snake.
That's all I can say to you.
Oh my god.
She's just so awful.
God each person is born with their fate written into their
own genetic code it's unchangeable immutable but that's not
all there is to life I finally realized that Naomi please
how long do I have you created this virus the reason that I
was interested in genes and DNA what how long do I know who
I was where I came from but what about me Naomi you're so i
analyzed my dna i could find out who i was who my parents oh
my god and i thought that if i knew that then i'd know what
path i should take in life just live just live just live
forehead i didn't find anything oh oticon's talking to me
i'm talking to oticon just like with the genome soldiers you
can input all the genetic information but that doesn't make
them into the strongest about DNA is that it governs a
person's potential strengths, potential destiny.
You mustn't allow yourself to be changed in fate, to be
ruled by your genes.
Humans can choose the type of life they want to live.
Smug.
Snake, whether or not you're in the Fox Die program isn't
important.
Don't trip.
The important thing is that you choose life.
then live live don't you think snake oh oh oh i'm going to
choose life too until today i've always looked for a reason
oh brother from here on i'm going to just live look at us
going down the little hill together we're so cute oh genes
exist to pass down our hopes and dreams for the keeps going
man she just keeps on going No more being used.
Living is a link to the future.
That's how all life works.
Loving each other.
Teaching each other.
Sorry, when it says loving each other and looks at Otacon,
please.
That's how we can change the world.
This game!
They know what they're doing.
I finally realized it.
The true meaning of life.
What is she yapping about?
Thank you, Snake.
That's me.
Thank you, Mint.
Oh, I'm driving.
Oh, my gosh.
I don't know how to...
Until today, I've lived only for myself.
Survival has been the only thing I cared about in my life.
That's not just you.
That's how everyone is.
I only felt truly alive when I was staring death in the
face.
I don't know.
Maybe it's written into my genes.
What about now?
I want to enjoy life.
I really do.
How about you, Otacon?
Me?
I feel like a new man.
So what are you going to do?
Continue your research?
No, I'm finished with science.
I'm interested in human psychology now.
Wow.
Sounds good.
The whole reason I got into science in the first place was
because I was no good with people.
Aww.
I was scared of them.
I was scared of life.
Same.
Well, you know.
I thought that I could never understand them because they're
so illogical.
But I finally learned how to like people.
You don't need people.
You have anime waifu now.
It's okay.
You and I are more alike than I thought.
I'm just tired of always being a spectator in life.
I'm ready to live.
I'm going to stand on my own two feet.
I'm not gonna hide anymore.
You're giving up your stealth, Camo?
Huh?
Well, can I have it?
Oh, yeah.
Can I have it?
You can have it.
Yippee!
Oh, my God.
Beaks down my heart.
This is where we say goodbye to our loves as well.
Want me to drive?
No, thanks.
I'd rather do it myself.
No problem.
problem where to snake oh my name real name is mint oticon
i'm hal dave oh that's right hal hal and dave that's a good
one maybe we should take a trip to jupiter so where are you
going dave mint i think it's time for me to look for a new
path a new path there's such dorks They're such dorks!
I'll find it.
What does that mean?
It's a reference to...
I know I'll find it.
To...
Odyssey.
2000 a space odyssey.
2001, sorry.
2001 a space odyssey.
Yay!
In the 1980s there were more than 60,000 nuclear warheads in
the world at all times.
power amounted to one million times that of the Hiroshima
A-bomb.
In January 1993, start two was signed and the United States
and Russia agreed to reduce the number of deployed strategic
nuclear warheads to 3,000 to 3,500 by December 3rd.
However, as of 1998, there still exists 26,000 nuclear
warheads in the world.
And...
Oh, text too fast.
Congrats on being in the game.
Thank you, Nashi.
Boo, politics?
Yo, don't get into Metal Gear then.
Metal Gear is all politics.
I
love this song so much.
Congrats on the cannon.
Liquid, beating Liquid up was the hardest boss.
Gow, thanks for the five gifting.
is in that snowmobile.
They're going to Fox Island.
There's a helicopter there.
Looks bad.
CQC rad.
Details inside.
Ah.
Here it goes.
Do-do-do-do-do.
That was early.
Oh.
We did it!
Whatever it is!
New headcanon mint is a ghost because Otakon fell in love
with it.
Oh god, that's brutal.
Congrats on reading the game again.
Thank you!
Didn't have comedic Otakon fall.
So true.
Oh, a little girl.
Oh, this song makes me cry.
Panda!
Thanks for the 20k.
I have to thank you!
Thank you!
That's why I thank you for the tip.
Thank you so much.
Man.
Mid-Mod made this 10 times better.
I thought it would be fun to kind of...
It wasn't my intention to save it for the finale, but...
I really wanted to...
make it possible for the finale.
If you heard that, that was my controller disconnecting.
Ha!
Ah!
Ooh, it's a mish!
I mean, just a sorry, singular mish.
Mushroom!
You protected the world from devastation.
United all nations within our...
Wait.
United...
Within our nation!
Announce the evils of truth and love!
Extended our reach to the skies above!
Minto!
Otakon!
United all nations within our nation.
Wait, is that actually it?
You know, this place is kind of beautiful.
No, I don't mean the flaming wreckage of dead bodies we left
behind us.
I mean Alaska.
Metal Gear, Metal, Metal, Mega 64 is Metal Gear Solid in
five minutes.
Actually, Mega 64 will be at MGScon.
And they, like, Rocco tweeted out.
was just like, getting ready for MGSCon, we realized that we
save everything.
And so I wonder what they'll be bringing to the convention.
I wonder maybe some secret stuff from when they did like the
commercials.
Like some props and stuff when they did the commercials for
MGS4.
It's pretty neat.
Always preferred the canon Meryl ending since Otacon gets
the cool self-sacrifice moment.
He doesn't sacrifice himself.
I mean, he still lives, but you know, I get it.
Congrats on beating MGS and getting an Otaku BF.
I would tame Otakon.
I would.
Very close to finishing Peace Walker.
That ending of Peace Walker is so frustrating and so good
and so beautiful.
I love it.
Thank you for all the super chats.
Raven's choice of the GAU-8 as his main weapon is comical.
heavy ammo hungry and long to be useful in this boss arena.
I mean, it's a good workout, you know?
Will he play as the angsty pretty boy next?
Of course!
So not this Saturday, but next Saturday, the 13th, we will
continue Metal Gear Saturdays with...
Wait.
Yeah.
What's that?
The 13th with Metal Gear Solid 2.
I wish I had started it in April.
So I could play it on April 30th.
But that's okay, too.
Now comes the Decoy Octopus Spy!
Yay!
Big shout-outs to Veri-Sec and...
Jebbles?
Yes, thank you, Veri-Sec!
Thank you, Jeremy.
Thank you both.
so much for putting this all together doing the figuring
very sick you are so cracked you are I I remember when when
the tweet went out about the mod like multiple people
message me being like did you see this and allow yourself to
be chained to fate to be ruled by your genes humans can
dream come true honestly seeing myself in the game so thank
you And then live.
Thanks, Naomi.
Metal Gear saw...
Yes, sir.
The entire unit was wiped out.
No, sir.
Those two are still alive.
The vector?
Yes, sir.
The box die should become activated soon.
Right on schedule.
Yes, sir.
I recovered all of Rex's dummy warhead data.
No, sir.
My cover is intact.
Nobody knows who I really am.
Yes, sir.
Yes, the DARPA chief knew my identity.
Oh.
But he's been disposed of.
Yes, sir.
Yes.
Thank you.
How am I getting it right?
Mr. President.
Oh, da, da, da, was that...
Isolat talking to the president?
Oh!
what does that mean oh wait this isn't my dang it this isn't
my door wait this isn't my this isn't my save what would i
have been i guess we'll never know no i might free time i'll
beat it on my normal account and i'll not my account on my
normal on the master collection and i'll tell you guys i'll
beat it in my well whenever i have free time but i'll let
you guys know i'll let you guys no
what does leper mean anyway though
finishing the game in five hours is nuts no no i did not do
that i did not do that cat no shut up you guys shut up
really good stats well Well, I had to still have really good
stats to finish the game, so...
Yippee!
Oh.
There we go.
Connected.
Yes.
The end credit song was sung in Irish.
I know.
That's why I've never sung it before.
I've seen...
What's pocket?
station yet oh memory card um i've seen like some english
covers done of the best is yet to come but
uh but um i don't know i i would have to i don't know i was
i feel like i've would have to mess around with it a little
bit i know donna burke has one too so i'm just gonna go to
here
oh demo wait does this work
oh it's just the autocon ending never mind the original just
hits it really dies it really dies one player view mode what
is that anyway one player view mode well guys we did it good
work boss thank you thank you thank you even with
performance anxiety first person view wait no way I
want to see what it's like very important to me ever since i
was eight years old i'm so happy to be oh no it's telling me
to tell me to put a disc one oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
there is no to ah ah ah well all have four time you know
what that's fine we finished it we finished it goodbye
goodbye metal gear no don't leave me metal gear i love you
metal gear i love you metal gear ah man um i'm gonna move
you guys i can't talk for too long just because i have to
get ready for leaving oh we can talk a little little bit.
Congrats on beating the game.
Will you be doing Ghost Babel before or after MGS2?
Oh!
Oh, whoops.
No, not my headband.
My headband and ammo.
Probably after.
I'll probably go through the main series and then do the
other games like Acid and Ghost Babel and stuff like that.
So it's a treat to watch.
Looking forward to the rest of the franchise.
I could honestly watch people play these games forever.
There's... Yeah, me too!
Just want to let you know Oh wait, hold on, let me put on
some music real quick Let me put on some music
There we go I have started the first part of rendering the
beeswax It's like a few days to get to the point where I can
make it into a candle Well be this to update you Let's go,
beeswax!
Andrea goes thanks to the pink!
It was so much fun watching you play through the game.
Thanks for the stream, looking forward to the next game.
Thank you!
I'm glad that, um...
That...
I didn't take like two hours on Rex.
I'm glad.
Great job, boss.
I can't make it to the concert, but I'll be cheering.
It's very, very lit!
Hope you have time to be here.
visit AX and pick up some merch.
I think BA is going to have a booth.
They are.
I honestly don't even know if I'm going to be able to go to
the con.
I actually have so much to do.
So I'm just kind of like, ah.
But if I do, cool.
If I don't, that's okay too.
Probably, honestly, if I don't, it saves me a big headache
from having to walk into AX.
It's worth.
Tomorrow, I have my first ever...
Wait, hold on.
I have my first ever...
Vlog.
Ta-da!
I went to a maid cafe!
And I am reporting on it.
So, if you are interested in Akiba Maid War...
Or not even just Akiba Maid War.
Just watch it.
Pog, vlog.
I possessed someone and I made her go for me.
I'm just like, I'm like inside this person.
They never knew that I was a ghost the whole time.
They never knew that I was a ghost inside someone's body.
Did you ask for consent?
I'm sure she enjoyed the trip.
I wonder if Mint will ever watch Escape from L.A.
No, no.
Not to escape from L.A.
Escape from New York!
The actual movie that inspired the Solid series.
I have seen Escape from New York, though.
I have not seen Escape from L.A., which is Escape from New
York, too.
But I have, I have.
I'm going to commission art in advance of you playing acid
in my ongoing campaign to girl, boss, gatekeep, and gaslight
you into playing acid, too.
I will play acid!
I'm going to not enjoy it.
I'm not going to have fun with acid, but I will play it.
Fake fan corrected.
I am a fan.
I was not going to say...
Wait, I was like, I am a fake fan, but then I was like, wait
a second.
No, I'm not.
Thanks for reminding me about AX.
I will be avoiding downtown LA on Friday.
But that's where my concert is.
Theocraft.
Yes, we have to go.
Or not.
You don't have to go.
But you know.
It'll be fun.
It'll be a fun time.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I'm going to be performing on a concert on Friday.
Which I'm very excited about.
I'm very nervous about what I was practicing today.
And everything.
But I have to also pack.
And...
Oh my God.
No!
Oh my gosh, I have to throw my rest of my laundry in the
dryer.
Okay, guys, I gotta get going so I can make sure that my
clothes dry on time.
Ah!
Thank you guys for Metal Gear Solid.
I hope you guys were surprised by the Minto model.
And I hope it was fun for you.
And we did it, baby!
In less than four hours.
Got through Vulcan Raven, Apal Keys, Rex, Liquid.
the car we did it baby we we did it good job to us thank you
so much and i hope you guys have a great night a great day
if you are in the united states i hope you have tomorrow off
and um yeah i'm gonna go finish getting ready oh my god I'll
see you, everyone!
I'll see you, and I'll see you.
Um, what was I going to say?
I'll see you.
Uh, uh, maybe Sunday.
Maybe Monday.
I'm not sure yet.
I'm going to try and do a gorilla stream on Sunday.
Hmm.
I'm going to try.
I'll see how I'm feeling.
Because it'll be a busy, busy weekend.
Anyway, Otsumito, see you next week!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye, bye-bye!
See you in a few days!
See you!
Bye-bye!
Guys, why is it every time I go to Twitter, I just see,
like, people's art of Doki's boobs?
What's going on?
This is, I'm not consenting to this.
I just see Doki's boobs all over my time.
Why is this happening to me?
I don't know.
Why are they all over my timeline?
Her birthday's tomorrow.
Wait, so she's in her birthday's suit?
Is that what you're telling me?
Is it Oimo?
Did she do one too?
No, I'm saying Nip Out.
I keep saying Art of her with Nip Out.
Doki, put on a shirt.
Anyway.
Okay.
that but they are for you man i don't want i never asked for
this oh yeah wait i did see oemos i thought you meant that
she did like a nsfw one no i saw that one too blink so i can
avoid